GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME BACK TO
SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR ON STATE
ADMINISTRATION.
TODAY WE'LL DISCUSS THE BUDGETS
OF THE PARTNER OF HOUSING EQUITY
DEVELOPMENT.
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FINANCING THE CALIFORNIA SCIENCE
CENTER. ZERO HOW ENOUGH MEMBERS
HERE FOR QUORUM MOST ARTISTS
THAT IS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
SO FOR SOMEONE WHO ITEM.
NUMBER ONE.
STATEWIDE HEALTH PACKAGE INTO
THE BILL LANGUAGE.
AND WHAT ACTUALLY UP WILL HOLD
OFF ON THIS WHEN IT WAS TO
CHOOSE INTERESTED.
IN THIS WHEN WE START WITH.
ALL OF US ARE THE ITEM NUMBER
NINE A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FINANCING.
TO THE BILL LANGUAGE STATE
SUPPLEMENTATION OF FOR COUNTY
ASSESSORS PROGRAM.
THE PROBLEM.
IF WE GET OUT FASTER. THEY GOT
THERE APPRECIATE IT.
DIRKSEN SUPPORT OF FINANCE GOOD
AFTERNOON.
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES A FIVE
MILLION APPROPRIATION EACH YEAR
FOR A THREE YEAR PERIOD.
FOR THE STATE'S IMPLEMENTATION
FOR COUNTY ASSESSORS.
.
PILOT PROGRAM.
WHICH WILL BE ADMINISTERED BY
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
THIS PILOT PROGRAM PROVIDES
FUNDING FOR COUNTY ASSESSORS.
TO PAY SALARIES AND BENEFITS FOR
NEW AND ADDITIONAL STAFF OR FOR
IT SYSTEMS.
TO ASSIST ASSESSMENT ACTIVITIES.
NO SINGLE CATHOLIC RECEIVE MORE
THAN FIFTEEN PERCENT OF THE
ANNUAL APPROPRIATION OF FIFTEEN
OR SO SENATE FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS THE GRANT PROGRAM
REQUIRES COUNTY MATCH ONE DOLLAR
FOR EVERY TWO DOLLARS.
IN GRANT FUNDS RECEIVED.
A IN THE PROPOSED PILOT PROGRAM
WE SEEK TO MEASURE THE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT AS VALIDATED AGAINST
PAY STAFFING NUMBERS.
BASED TASK PERFORMED AND BASS
COUNTY WIDEASSESSED VALUES.
THIS IS SO MUCH OF THE OF. THE
INITIAL STATE COUNTY SUCH AS
PILOT PROGRAM THAT WAS.
APPROPRIATED BACK IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN THE BUDGET ACT.
BECAUSE I TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
LET ME ILLEGAL.
O. WE GREW THE ADMINISTRATION
THERE'S A REASON WHY ARGUMENT
FOR PROVIDING ADDITIONAL STATE
FUNDING A TWO ASSESSORS WE
SUGGEST.
THE LEGISLATURE IF THEY MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS PROPOSAL
CONSIDER A FEW CHANGES.
TO THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL.
FIRST IS NARROWING THE FOCUS OF
THE FUNDING OF THE ALWAYS OF THE
FUNDING TO TECHNOLOGY UPGRADES
OF THEN ASSESSOR'S OFFICES THIS
WOULD HAVE A COUPLE OF
ADVANTAGES.
A ONE AS OPPOSED TO FOCUSING ARE
BOTH ON STAFF AND TECHNOLOGY IS
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
FOCUSING.
JUST ON TECHNOLOGY WOULD ALLOW
THE FUNDING TO BE SPREAD ACROSS
MORE COUNTIES.
IN ADDITION A TECHNOLOGY
UPGRADES COULD HAVE A MORE
LASTING IMPACT IN ASSESSOR'S
OFFICES WHERE IS OF LIMITED TERM
STAFF PRESUMABLY. A WOULD BE
GONE AT THE END OF THE THREE
YEAR PILOT.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND.
CHANGING THE STRUCTURE OF THE
COUNTY MATCH THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES THAT FOR EVERY DOLLAR
PUT UP BY THE STATE THE COUNTY
IS. A BE REQUIRED TO SUPPLY
FIFTY CENTS.
WE SUGGEST CHANGING IT SO THAT
NOT TO FUND A TECHNOLOGY PROJECT
OF THE COUNTY WOULD PAY A SHARE
OF THE COST THAT'S.
A PROPORTIONATE TO THE SHARE
PROPERTY TAXES THEY RECEIVED IN
THE COUNTY THE STATE WOULD PAY A
SHARE THAT'S PROPORTIONATE.
TO THE SHARE PROPERTY TAXES ARE
SHE BY SCHOOLS AND IN DOING SO
YOU WOULD A LINE. OF THE COSTS
OF THE PROJECT PAID BY BOTH THE
STATE THE COUNTY A BETTER WITH
THE BENEFITS IN TERMS OF
PROPERTY TAXES THAT THEY WOULD
RECEIVE.
THANK YOU OR ANNOYED PAUSINI'S
W. QUORUM PLEASE.
WE WILL FALL.
COOPER HERE ALAN.
CABALLERO.
CHIU CHOI.
THE QUESTION THE COMMITTEE.
YOU'VE WRITTEN A PUBLIC WAS
INCOME ON THIS ITEM.
GOOD RECOGNITION TO HOLD OPEN SO
HOLD OPEN.
NOW MOVE BACK TO ISSUE NUMBER.
OVATION OVER TEN.
WHICH IS PROFITABILITY.
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
INTERN TWENTY THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION TOOK DOLLARS TO
REIMBURSE.
CITIES COUNTIES AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS FOR PROPERTY TAX
LOSSES RESULTING FROM THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN FIRES.
THESE REIMBURSEMENTS WILL
CURRENT TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FISCAL YEARS.
THIS IS SO MUCH THE
REIMBURSEMENTS PROVIDED LAKE IN
CALAVERAS COUNTY IS THAT WHERE.
APPROPRIATE IN THE BUDGET ACT
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
A SINCE THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
FIRES.
WERE STILL BURNING WHEN WE
DEVELOPED THE.
.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BACK IN
JANUARY.
WE'RE ACTIVELY WORKING WITH THE
COUNTIES TO CLICK PROPERTY TAX
LOSS INFORMATION WILL HAVE A
BETTER ESTIMATE.
IN TIME FOR THE MAY REVISE.
THE TO ANSWER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
YEAH I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION WILL
THE NUMBERS TO BE UPDATED TO
REFLECT THE WILDFIRES IN THE
NORTH AND SOUTH STATE. INCLUDE
THE DAMAGE MUDSLIDES IT'LL BE
PART OF THE MAY REVIVE US OKAY.
A QUESTION COMMITTEE.
THE FIRST REPUBLICAN COMETS.
OKAY WILL I HOPE WE DO HAVE ONE
COMMENT.
MY APOLOGIES MISTER CHAIRED
MEMBERS I FOR MCVEIGH TING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF THE SIDE OF. THE.
PARDON.
DAVID JONES ABOUT THE CITY
CENTER ZEROES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AND FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
GET RECOGNITION OVERSIGHT OF
LOCAL HOLD OPEN.
NOW MOVE BACK TO ITEM NUMBER
ONE.
STATE WHAT HOUSING PACKAGE INTO
THE BILL LANGUAGE
.
WOULD YOU HAVE ILLEGAL FINANCES
ON THE TOP PLEASE
.
HOWEVER.
MR CHOICES DELIVERY. THANK YOU
DOCTOR CHOI.
WHEN NOBODY.
PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SUSAN COULD DESCEND. AND AT THE
END OF THIS WEEK I WILL
CELEBRATE MY THREE MONTHS WITH
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
ADMINISTRATION AND MANAGEMENT
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING.
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT I'D
LIKE TO ALLOW MY COLLEAGUES TO
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS LISA
BATES I'M CURRENTLY THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE GOING ON
ABOUT SEVEN MONTHS IN THIS
CURRENT RURAL.
AS ECHO INSTEAD W. ACTOR FREE TO
THE.
FOR THEIR HOUSING POLICIES.
DEVELOPMENT.
OUR DIVISION.
NOT GOING TO LEAD OFF THE
DISCUSSION WITH AN OVERVIEW OF
THE BCP.
FOR DECADES CALIFORNIA HAS FACED
A SHORTAGE OF HOUSING DUE TO
HISTORICAL UNDER PRODUCTION OF
ADEQUATE SUPPLY WE COMPARED TO
DEMAND.
WHILE THE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
STATEWIDE HOUSING ASSESSMENT
IDENTIFIED ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND UNITS OF HOUSING
NEEDED ANNUALLY TO HOUSE THE
GROWING POPULATION OVER THE NEXT
TEN YEARS.
ONLY AN AVERAGE OF ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND UNITS HAVE BEEN
PRODUCED ANNUALLY OVER THE LAST
EIGHT YEARS.
BECAUSE OF THIS HISTORICAL UNDER
PRODUCTION OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE NOW
HOMELESS AND ON SHELTER.
RENT COSTS ARE CONSUMING AN EVER
LARGER PORTION OF INCOMES AND
WELL INTENDED BUT BURDENSOME
REGULATIONS CONTINUE TO INHIBIT
THE CONSTRUCTION OF NEW HOUSING.
IN RESPONSE TO THIS CRISIS THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
DEVELOPED A LEGISLATIVE HOUSING
PACKAGE.
A FIFTEEN BILLS THAT THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED INTO LINE
SEPTEMBER TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
TODAY EACH CD IS REQUESTING
AUTHORITY FOR POSITIONS AND
FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT THIS
HOUSINGS PACKAGE.
PACIFIC KLAY EACH CD REQUESTS.
STEAM MILLION DOLLARS AND EIGHTY
ONE POSITIONS FOR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS AND
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
POSITIONS AND TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY.
AND TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
AND ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
POSITIONS ONGOING FOR STATE
OPERATIONS TO IMPLEMENT THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN HOUSING
PACKAGE.
EACH CITY ALSO REQUESTS
FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. AND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS I'M GOING AND
LOCAL ASSISTANCE.
LL.
YES THINGS ARE CHAIR OF WE THINK
THAT THE OVERALL REQUESTS A
STAFFING WESTERN A CD IS
REASONABLE.
IT'S IN LINE WITH THE
APPROPRIATIONS ANNOUNCES MET
WITH THE BILL'S OF THEY MOVED TO
THE PROCESS AND ALSO ONLINE WITH
STAFFING LEVELS ARE PASSED A
BOND MEASURES. A WE DO OFFER A
COUPLE COMMENTS WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER FIRST IS
OF THAT THE DIRECTION GIVEN TO
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
EXPENDITURE OF THE FIRST YEAR
REVENUES UNDER S. B. TWO. FOR
HOMELESS OF THE SERVICES.
WAS.
NOT VERY SPECIFIC UPDATE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
UNDERTAKE A STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
THAT WOULD SHAPE HOW THOSE FUNDS
A WOULD BE USED ABOUT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WANT TO PROVIDE MORE FORMAL
GUIDANCE THEIR TRAILER BILL OR
SOME OTHER VEHICLE. ON HOW YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT FUNDING
SPENT.
OH BY WE ALSO SUGGEST THAT THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF UNCERTAINTIES
ABOUT HOW THESE. THE
IMPLEMENTATION THESE BILLS MOVE
FORWARD AND SOME OF THE OF
PROGRAMS THAT WILL BE FUNDED
WITH SOME OF THE NEW REVENUE
STREAMS. AND.
AND BECAUSE OF THESE
UNCERTAINTIES THE BILL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER A WITHHOLDING APPROVAL
OF ADDITIONAL STAFFING RAMP UPS
IN NINETEEN TWENTY. AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE.
UNTIL FUTURE BUDGET PROCESS
HE'S TO ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO
COME BACK AND HAVE FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS AND ALLOW FOR
FURTHER OVERSIGHT. OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE OF THE
HOUSING PACKAGE.
FINANCE.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I MAY
INTERROGATIVE ON A FINANCE WE
HAVE TWO SEPARATE COMMENTS ONE
IS JUST IN REGARDS TO A
TECHNICAL CHANGE TO
PROVISIONALLY WHICH. WITH ONE
ITEM RELATED TO THIS P. C. P.
AND ONE RELATED TO THE VETERANS
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS PENSION
BCP. IT'S A TECHNICAL LANGUAGE
CHANGE THAT WE'VE SHARED WITH
THE LA ON YOUR STAFF.
AND THEN.
BUT.
ARE SECOND COMMENT IS REGARDS
TO THE AYE LEOS AND CONCERNS
ABOUT STAFFING FOR NEW PROGRAMS
AND FUNDING SOURCES WHILE WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THOSE CONCERNS WE
RECOMMEND APPROVING THE
POSITIONS IN THE OUT YEARS. I'M
BECAUSE WE THINK IT MAKES SENSE
TO BUILD IN MULTI YEAR POSITIONS
IN THIS CASE. I'M OUR PROPOSAL
ALREADY REFLECTS A RAMPING UP OF
POSITION AUTHORITY WHICH IS
PHASED IN OVER TIME TO REFLECT A
FEE.
HIRING TIMELINE AND GIVEN THE
INCREASE IN THE SIZE OF THE
DEPARTMENT WE BELIEVE THE MULTI
YEAR AUTHORITY IS NECESSARY TO
ADEQUATELY PLAN FOR NEW
POSITIONS AND PROVIDE FOR A
SMOOTH ONBOARDING PROCESS.
HER FREE CD CAN EXPLAIN HOW YOU.
PLAN TO USE THE.
S. B. TO FUNDING FOR THE FIRST
YEAR.
YEAH PREVENT TALK ABOUT THAT.
THE AS AS YOU KNOW HALF THE
FUNDS ARE SPENT BETWEEN
HOMELESSNESS USES HALF FOR
PLANNING.
.
THE HOME WITH THIS USES I WANT
TO LAY OUT CAN OF OUR PRINCIPLES
THAT WE'VE THOUGHT THROUGH AND
AND WHAT OUR PLAN OF ATTACK IS.
SO DETERMINING HOW TO DISTRIBUTE
IF YOU FUNDS DOES NEED FOR
HOMELESSNESS WE CUT IT THE
FOLLOWING PRINCIPLES.
THAT FUNDS SHOULD BE ALLOCATED
DIRECTLY LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS SHOULD HAVE
SIGNIFICANT FLEXIBILITY IN
DECIDING HOW TO USE THE FUNDS TO
BEST SERVE THE HOMELESS NEEDS IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
FUNDS SHOULD BE DISTRIBUTED TO
AND THEY'RE NON COMPETITIVE
PROCESS USING EQUITABLE
ALLOCATION FORMULA.
LW SHOULD INCLUDE INTERVENTIONS
THAT CAN BE QUICKLY DEPLOYED TO
ASSIST HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES AND SHOULD INCLUDE USES
THAT ARE GAPS IN THE CURRENT
AVAILABILITY OF FUNDING. AND THE
DESIRE TO ALLOCATE THE FIRST TWO
QUARTERS OF S. B. TO REVENUES AS
QUICKLY AS THE SECOND QUARTER OF
FUNDS BECOMES AVAILABLE.
IN LOOKING INTO NOW IT IT WAS
AND HOW WE HOW WE GO ABOUT DOING
THAT WE LOOK AT OUR CLOSEST ALLY
MEANT TO ACHIEVING THIS
PRINCIPLES. POSSIBLY BEING OUR
BURJI SOLUTIONS GRANT PROGRAM.
BUT OUR SYSTEM IS THAT MANY
CHANGES ARE NEEDED TO THAT
PROGRAM ON WORKING WITH
SUCCESSFUL INTO PROPERLY FILL
THE GAPS IN THE SYSTEM AS I
MENTIONED.
THEREFORE WE WANT TO
SIGNIFICANTLY MODIFY.
WHAT HAVE BEEN THE TRADITIONAL
RICH SOLUTIONS GRANT PROGRAM
USES?
AND ACTIVITIES AND USE SB TO
FUNDS FOR THE FOLLOWING ELVES
WILL USE.
RENTAL ASSISTANCE WHICH COULD
INCLUDE RAPIDLY HOUSING WITH
EXPANDED FLEXIBILITY BEYOND
CURRENT PROGRAM PARAMETERS.
OPERATING SUBSIDIES IN THE
FORMER FIFTEEN YEAR CAPITALIZE
OPERATING RESERVES IN NEW AND
EXISTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS TO DEEPLY TARGET THOSE
UNITS TO CALIFORNIANS ASK
TEXTING HOMELESSNESS.
THIS IS WHAT THE MOST DIFFICULT
ASPECTS OF FUNDING INCREASING
PERMITS WERE HOUSING RIGHT NOW.
LOCAL PROGRAMS THAT ESTABLISH OR
SUPPORT FLEXIBLE HOUSING SUBSIDY
POOL THE POOL AVAILABLE LOCAL
DOLLARS TO COMMIT RENTAL
SUBSIDIES.
TO PRIVATE LANDLORDS AND
SUPPORTIVE AND FOR WILL HOUSING
PROVIDERS.
OPERATING SUPPORT FOR SHORT TERM
EVER EMERGENCY HOUSING
INTERVENTIONS SUCH AS NAVIGATION
CENTERS. THAT PROVIDE TEMPORARY
ROOM ABOARD WITH LIMITED
BARRIERS TO ENTRY WELL CASE
MANAGERS WORK TO CONNECT
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS WITH AND
FAMILY'S INCOME PUBLIC BENEFITS
HEALTH SERVICES SHELTER AND
HOUSING.
LANDLORD INCENTIVES SUCH AS
SUBSIDIES FOR LANDLORDS WHILE
WAITING FOR HOUSING CHOICE
VOUCHER APPROVAL AND RESERVES
FOR UNEXPECTED VACANCIES.
AND SYSTEM SUPPORT FOR COURTNEY
TO ENTER SYSTEMS DIVERSION
PROGRAMS AND SERVICE
INTEGRATION.
DATA AND WHO WITH MANAGEMENT
INFORMATION SYSTEMS REPORTING
AND HOMELESSNESS PLANNING.
SO BUT TO MAINTAIN CONTINUITY WE
WOULD DISTRIBUTE THESE FUNDS NON
COMPETITIVELY THROUGH LOCAL
CONTAINS OF CARE THEY RECEIVE
MOST FEDERAL HOMELESSNESS
FUNDING. WOULD MODIFY THE EGGS
ARE EXISTING CALIFORNIA EST
FORMULA TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
FACTORS SUCH AS HOMELESS POINT
TIME COUNT DATA PRINTER COST
BURDEN AND POVERTY RATE.
AND THESE WERE SAID TO BE FUNDS
THEIR BLOCK GRANTED AND MUCH
MORE PERMISSIVE AND USES THROUGH
THE MENU OF ELIGIBLE ACTIVITIES
I REFERENCED. WHERE EACH
CONTINUE OF CARE WILL DETERMINE
HOW THEY BREAK DOWN THERE USES
WITHIN THAT MENU OF OPTIONS?
AND SINCE WE HAVE A PROXY TWENTY
FIVE MILLION REMAINING
CALIFORNIA EST FUNDING WOULD
APPLY THESE PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES
TO BOTH OUR REMAINING FUNDS
THEIR AND OUR S. B. TO HOMELESS
FUNDS AND PULL THEM INTO ONE
NOTICE A FUNDING BILL BILL THE
IN ORDER TO INCREASE THE EASE.
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND TO LEVERAGE
BIGGER FUNDING. WE WOULD OFFER
SEPARATE NO FOR. FOR FEDERAL YES
HE FUNDS IN JUNE SINCE WE CANNOT
MAKE CHANGES TO THE FEDERAL.
WE EXPECT IT TO THE THAT THE
SECOND QUARTER OF SB TO REVENUES
TO IT WILL BE PERMITTED FROM THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE BY THE END
OF JULY. SORE CURRENT STATUTORY
AUTHORITY WOULD ALLOW LIST
PROPOSED DRAFT GUIDELINES OFFER
THEM FOR THIRTY DAY PUBLIC
COMMENT. PERIOD IN JUNE WITH A
NO FOUR ON THE STREETS IN AUGUST
WE COULD TURN AROUND THIS BLOCK
GRANT FUNDS THAT SIXTY DAYS OF
APPLICATION.
AND THEN THE PLANNING GRANT SIDE
AND A WEST OF THE OF THAT WE
ACTUALLY NEED THE FULL AMOUNT OF
THE REVENUES ARE AS OUR PLAN FOR
THOSE FUNDS TO BE DEPLOYED. US
SO WE CAN KNOW HOW MUCH WILL BE
AVAILABLE EACH AND EVERY DURING
A LOCAL JURISDICTION BUT WE WILL
BE ABLE BEGAN OFFERING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FUNDS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ON HOW THEY WOULD
ACCESS PLANNING GRANTS IN THE
LATTER HALF OF THIS YEAR'S. SO I
SO I HAVE THE CURRENT ESG FUNDS
GONE OUT.
WILL THEY HAVE WE WERE WE WERE
AWARDED.
WE ORDERED SOME FUNDS IN
PREVIOUS BUDGET YEARS AND WE HAD
PLANNED TO CONTINUE THAT OVER
COUPLE YEAR PERIOD. ARE WE
TYPICALLY HAVE A LINE THAT WITH
OUR FEDERAL FUNDS RATE AND THE
REASON WHY WE HAVEN'T GOT HAVE
GONE OUT SO FAR THIS YEAR'S HOW
DOES NOT GIVE WITH OUR FEDERAL
FUNDS WHO'VE ALREADY KIND OF IN
A WEEK AND GET WAITING WAITING
GAME THERE. SO.
IN THIS CASE WE WOULD SEPARATE
OUT THE CALIFORNIA SEA PROGRAM
AND JUST.
EYELINER POOL THAT'S BE TWO
FOOT DOLLARS WITH THEM AS WELL.
AND OUR EXPECTATION IS WE WILL
GET OUR FEDERAL YES YOU FUNDS
FROM HYDE.
SO WHAT SOON AND BE ABLE TO
OFFER THOSE FROM. HOW MUCH MONEY
S. B. PULL THE GO OUT?
WITH THAT IN TERMS OF SO ABOUT
WE HAVE ABOUT.
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE MILLION IN
CALIFORNIA IF YOU FUNDS ON THE
FEDERAL AND FEDERALLY WE HAVE
ABOUT I THINK ELEVEN OR TWELVE
TWELVE MILLION.
THE TWELVE NAY FEDERAL FUNDS
WOULD GO OUT HAS ALWAYS HAPPENED
ANNUALLY.
IN VIEW ASSUMING WE GET THE
FUNDS ARE HARD WHEN WE EXPECT TO
AND THEN WE WOULD PULL THE
REMAINING CALIFORNIA SECRETIVE
WITH THESE NEW EXPANDED PROGRAM
USES.
COMBINED IT'S BEAUTIFUL IT'S
IMPARTED PARTLY A PART OF OUR
DECISION MAKING THERE IS.
THE CALIFORNIA SEA FUNDS ARE A
LOT MORE LIMITED IN WHAT THEY
CAN DO.
.
TYPICALLY IS THE OUTLOOK FOR
THIS RAPID RE HOUSING MONEY THAT
HAS PUT AND CHALLENGES OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT THE LOCAL LEVEL
BECAUSE THERE'S WE'RE TYING
THOSE TO CUT THE FEDERAL
PARAMETERS AND HOW MUCH RENT
ASSISTANCE THEY CAN PROVIDE. AN
ARCHIMEDES ARE RENTS IN THE
COMPETITION ARE MAKING THREE FOR
SO GREAT THAT DEFERRAL REAL
LIMITATION AT SOME OF THE
JURISDICTIONS BILL EXPAND THOSE
FUNDS. TO THINK YOU GET BETTER
UTILITY IF WE JUST EXPANDED WE
FILL THE DAY WITH THESE EXPANDED
PROGRAM USES AND FREE UP.
SOME OF OF SOME OF THE.
AVAILABLE KIND OF OPTIONS TO
COMMUNITIES TO SILICON REFLECT
THE ACTUAL NEEDS THERE WHAT IS
THE CURRENT FIX HE READ A CD.
LEARN YOUR VACANCIES.
THE AVERAGE OF THE MONTHLY
VACANCY RATE FOR TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN IS THIRTEEN
PERCENT.
BUT ACCOUNTING FOR THE UNFUNDED
NO PLACE LIKE HOME POSITIONS THE
RATE IS APPROXIMATELY NINE
PERCENT.
FOR TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THROUGH JANUARY THE
MONTHLY AVERAGE WAS SIXTEEN
POINT FOUR PERCENT.
BUT ACCOUNTING AGAIN FOR THOSE
NO PLACE LIKE HOME POSITIONS THE
RATE IS APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN
PERCENT.
SO WHAT'S YOUR PLAN TO BRING ON
BOARD IT WILL STAFF POSITIONS
FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
OUR PLAN IS TO HIRE IN WAVES
FIRST FOCUSING ON THE SP TWO
POSITIONS.
WE'VE DEVELOPED A PROJECT
PLANNER WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
I'VE HAD. REFINING OUR PROJECT
PLAN FOR MANAGING THE EFFORT AS
ACROSS ORGANIZATIONAL PROJECT
FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
AND AYE WERE APPROACHING IT
STRATEGICALLY SO THAT WERE
PLANNING THAT THAT WILL ON BOARD
POSITIONS AND PEOPLE IN A WAY
THAT WILL SUPPORT. THE
ONBOARDING ACTIVITIES AS WELL AS
THE ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT SO THAT FIRST
WAVE WOULD BE WHAT TIME PERIOD.
AND WHAT IS FAR AS NUMBERS GO.
THE FIRST WAVE I THINK THAT I
HAD BETWEEN SP TWO AND AND
IRVINE RATHER THE SP THREE
POSITIONS AS APPROXIMATELY HALF
OF THE EIGHTY ONE POSITIONS
REQUESTED IN THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR.
SO WE'D FIRST BEFORE KISSING ON
THE OTHER HALF OF POSITIONS
WITHIN THE FIRST HALF OF THE
FISCAL YEAR.
OKAY SO JUST BASICALLY TO WAVE
THEN.
YES ALTHOUGH I THINK THE NUANCES
THAT THERE MAY BE A LEADER WAVE
OF FOR S. B. THREE. I'VE HAD.
THAT THE RECRUITMENT WOULD BEGIN
WITHIN THIS COMING FISCAL YEAR.
BUT WOULD BE CONCLUDED MOVING
INTO THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR
MISTER.
I THINK MISTER CHAIRPERSON ME.
START ST.
NOT JUST AS A MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE BUT AS THE CHAIR OF
THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. THANKS TO A EIGHT CD
AND EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM WHO
WORK TO TO PASS OUT LAST YEAR'S.
HOUSING PACKAGE.
IT WAS A BIG LEFT AND I'M GLAD
WE ARE WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
AND I WANTED JUST TO SHARE WITH
YOU IN OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE I'M
PREPARED TO SUPPORT THE STAFFING
LEVEL THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS PACKAGE. GETS
IMPLEMENTED AS QUICKLY AND AS
EFFECTIVELY AS WE NEED TWO SO UP
LOOK FOR TO THAT CONVERSATION.
MR HOMESTEAD I KNOW RECENTLY
WORKED IN THE LEGISLATURE SO I
THINK HE ANTICIPATED A LOT OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT I HAD. ABOUT
HOW SOME THESE FUNDS MIGHT BE.
MIGHT BE USED BUT.
TOP LEVEL WHAT YOU JUST TOLD US
ABOUT CHANGES THAT YOU WANT I
PROPOSE TO ESG. ARM IS THAT.
TUMMY THE PROCESS UNDER WHICH
THOSE CHANGES WOULD HAVE
YES SO WE WOULD.
WE WOULD ISSUE WE WE TYPICALLY
ALLOW FOR OPEN PUBLIC COMMENT ON
OUR OUR OUR OUR GOD LET YOUR
VISION STILL WE.
ARE TIME LIMITS WOULD BE
PREPARED TO.
BEGIN THAT JUNE FIRST WOULD
HAVE A THIRTY DAY COMMENT PERIOD
AND WE FINALIZE THOSE GUIDELINES
IN JULY.
WE EXPECT THE SECOND QUARTER OF
LOVE THAT'S BE TO FUNDS TO
DETERMINE IF LOOKING TOWARDS
OFFICE AT THE END OF JULY SO
FOOLISH WITH LAUGHTER BY MID
AUGUST WE PUT OUR NOTICE OF
FUNDING AVAILABILITY ON THE
STREET WITH THAT REVISED.
WITH THOSE REVISED IN FOR THE
FINAL GUIDELINES THAT WE WOULD
MEAN FINALIZING JULY AND WHAT
YOU JUST DESCRIBED IF THE
CHANGES POTENTIALLY TSG OR IS
THAT IS ALREADY PUBLIC.
NO OKAY YOU'RE YOU'RE BREAKING
IS THAT'S WHY THAT'S WHY IT'S SO
I THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT.
WOULD LOVE IF MAYBE WE CAN GET
THAT IN WRITING SO THAT WE COULD
START MULLING OVER IT AND LET ME
JUST SAY THAT.
VIC THE ONE PROGRAM THAT
FUNDING FROM SPT COULD BE
PLUGGED INTO WITH THE COURTS TO
FUND IT S. YESTERDAY AND. WE ALL
KNOW THAT YES SHE REALLY HAS NOT
DONE A VERY GOOD JOB OF
ADDRESSING CHRONIC HOMELESS.
ADDRESSES
OF FOLKS WHO'VE RECENTLY COME
HOMELESS.
WITH RENTAL ASSISTANCE BUT I
THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT. WE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO BALANCE
SOLUTIONS THAT ADDRESS CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS WITH ADDRESSING
SHORT TERM HOMELESSNESS AND IT
SOUNDS TO ME.
JUST BASED ON WHAT I HEARD THAT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
THINKING HARD ABOUT THAT.
ABOUT THAT QUESTION ON.
ONE QUESTION. TO YOU.
DO YOU HAVE EVIDENCE ABOUT HOW
ESG HAS BEEN WORKING AT LEAST IN
ADDRESSING SHORT TERM
HOMELESSNESS DO YOU HAVE. DATA
THEIR WAYS FOR STATES TO TRACK
THAT INFORMATION AROUND GRANT
RECIPIENTS.
DOES THAT INFORMATION EXIST YEAH
I MEAN WE CERTAINLY WE GET
REPORTS OBVIOUSLY.
FROM FROM THE GRANTEES.
THAT THE CURRENTLY HAVE
RECEIVED THIS.
I KNOW YOU KNOW THAT THAT THE
USES ARE OR MORE LIMITED RIGHT
IT'S.
YOU CAN YOU SOME MONEY FOR
MERGING SHELTER.
YOU CAN USE MONEY FOR LIKE
RAPPER HOUSING ARE THE DATA WE
GET IS MOSTLY MORE LIKE PERSON
SERVED RATHER THAN REALLY GREAT
OUTCOME DATA OBVIOUSLY WE WOULD
HAVE AN INTEREST IN. YOU KNOW
GETTING AS BAD AS BEST DATA
DRIVEN OUTCOME DATA WITH THESE
FUNDS AS WE CAN AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE.
AND I IMAGINE WE WILL HEAR IN
PUBLIC ON THAT YOU KNOW PERCENT
OF THE PUSH AND PULL AND THEN
THAT THEIR SUPREME THING AND HOW
MUCH THEY WANT TO BE REQUIRED OF
THEM VERSUS.
WHAT WE WOULD LOVE TO ASK FOR
FOR DATA PROJECT PERSPECTIVE BUT
CERTAINLY WE WANT TO BUILD A TO
THIS SOME EXPECTATION THAT WE
SEE?
ESPECIALLY SINCE IT FOR
PROVIDING A SIGNIFICANT
FLEXIBILITY IN PERSON THIS ND
HOW LOOKOUT HE MADE ME USE THOSE
FUNDS TO SAY OKAY IF YOU'RE.
DECIDED YOU FUNDS A CERTAIN
WAKING PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOUR HOW MAYBE WE'RE
GONNA SERVER WHAT HOW CAN YOU
HOPE TO YOU HOPE TO ACHIEVE BY
THAT THAT'S CERTAINLY AN OUTCOME
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
I THINK YOU KNOW WE DON'T REALLY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO.
GATHER A LOT OF LOCAL THAT AT
THE STATE LEVEL I PRESENT YOU
KNOW SOMETHING THAT OUR WHOLE
ACCORDING TO FIND TO COUNSEL'S
NEED A PRIORITY OF.
WE CERTAINLY HAVE BEGUN TO LOOK
INTO BUT OF COURSE WE DON'T HAVE
A STATE LEVEL SYSTEM THAT WE
WOULD LIKE IN TERMS OF THE
CAPABLE YOU'RE GETTING AT.
TO REALLY DO THE GREAT
EVALUATION I THINK THAT'S NEED
TO MAKE MORE MORE INFORMED
DECISIONS.
BUT WE DO RECOGNIZE I THINK THIS
DIFFERENCE NEED OF SERVING FOLKS
NOW AND SO THAT'S WHY YOU HEAR
THE THE MENU OF THINGS.
I THINK GET GOOD AT THAT BUT
ALSO WITH THE AYE ON GETTING A
CHRONICLE ASSISTANCE IN THIS
LONG TERM SOLUTIONS THAT WE TALK
ABOUT. YOU LOCAL HOUSING SUBSIDY
APPLICABLE SUBSEA POOLS OR WHAT
DOES ACTUALLY THAT LEVERAGE
OTHER FUNDING THAT CAN BE USED
TO AUGMENT OR SUPPLEMENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING I THINK WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO SEE. COMMUNITIES
OMICS OF THOSE CHOICES BUT.
BUT WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THE NEED
TO ADDRESS A WHOLE CONTINUUM OF
ELICITED FROM FOR SHELTER DEL
ON%
TO PERMANENT POSITION CREATED
YOUR ANSWER ON THAT AND AND
CERTAINLY FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I
THINK ANYTHING YOU CAN DO TO
COLLECT MORE DATA. SOONER THAN
LATER IS AS HELPFUL.
YOU MAY KNOW THAT I HAVE A BILL
THAT WOULD.
IT WOULD TO ASK EACH CD TO
START COLLECTING LOCAL DATA SO
THAT WE HAVE A BIGGER PICTURE OF
OF EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON IN
OUR. FUNDS CAN BE BEST USED
PUMP.
A DIFFERENT QUESTION I HAD WE
ALL SHARE THE GOAL OF WANTING TO
GET MONIES OUT TO OUR LOCALITIES
AS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE TO
GIVE THEM. FLEXIBILITY
ANDADDRESSING THE CRISES THAT
ARE
HAPPENING ON THE STREETS OF OF
CITIES AND COUNTIES. OF BUT I
THINK THERE'S A BALANCE BETWEEN
WANTING TO GET MONEY OUT. TO
LOCALS TO BE USED AS A SEE FIT.
VERSES WANTING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE MONIES ARE WELL SPENT AND
I'M WONDERING HOW DO YOU PLAN TO
BALANCE THOSE NEEDS IF THEY'RE
CITIES TO. ONE IT'S BEEN MONIES
IN CERTAIN WAYS BETTER ONLY
ADDRESSING PARTS OF THE ISSUE
HOW THE BALANCE FLEXIBILITY WITH
MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S ACTUAL
OUTCOME SAID THAT WORK FOR US.
YEAH I MEAN I THINK I THINK
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GONNA GO UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT EXPLORE SOME
THESE QUESTIONS ON
ACCOUNTABILITY LIKE HOW HOW MUCH
CAN WE.
DEMAND OF OF RECIPIENTS
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE
GOING TO CUT MORE BLOCK GRANT
MODEL.
HOW FAR CAN WE PUSH ON SOME OF
THOSE?
?
SO I DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER TODAY
RIGHT BECAUSE I THINK WE WE
ANTICIPATE THAT'S GOING TO BE A
MAJOR MAJOR POINT OF KIND OF
DISCUSSION AND AS WE DO
WORKSHOPS ON THE DRAFT
GUIDELINES ARE ENCRYPTED BACK
FROM MULTIPLE LITTLE PARTIES.
BUT I REST ASSURED IT'S
SOMETHING WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
INTERNAL DISCUSSION ABOUT ABOUT
HOW DO WE HAVE THAT APPROPRIATE
CAN ABILITY AND CAN GET THAT OUT
OF PEACE.
NOT TO SAY YOU KNOW WE DON'T
SEE THAT THERE'S ONLY CERTAIN
THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE I THINK
SOME THE CRITICISM CRITICISM
OBVIOUSLY IN THE PAST AS WE WERE
MAYBE OVERLY PRESCRIPTIVE AND
HOW MUCH MONEY HAD TO BE SO
UNCERTAIN THINGS. WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE WE HEARD SOME OF THAT
TOO.
BUT.
BUT CERTAINLY SURE THAT GOAL ON
ACCOUNTABILITY ABSOLUTELY.
YEAH WELL SAMIR DID NOT MENTION
YOU KNOW.
SOME OTHER THINGS WE HAVE BUT
WE WE WE DO WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT WE HAVE SOME OF THE FORCES
ON THE CAPITAL SIDE FOR PERMITS
FOR OF HOUSING.
STILL ABLE TO BE DEPLOYED FROM
THE DEPARTMENT SO WE TOOK THAT
INTO ACCOUNT AS WELL IN TERMS
OF.
THE FUNDS WE MAY BE ABLE TO
STILL THE POINT FOR OUR MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAM FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING OR HOPEFULLY
WHEN I YOU KNOW POLITICAL FUNDS
ARE UNLOCKED. AYE WE ALSO COURSE
HAVE A BETTER NEEDS A HOUSING
HOMES PREVENTION PROGRAM WHICH
IS UP THE VETERANS FOCUS BUT
RIGHT FOR SUPPORT HOUSING SO WE
WERE NOT MINDFUL THAT WE HAD A
LOT OF POTENTIAL WRITTEN
RESOURCES OUT THERE. ON THE
CAPITAL SIDE WE THOUGHT HOW CAN
WE SUPPORT THAT AND AUGMENT THAT
HELP THOSE HAPPEN QUICKER BUT BE
MINDFUL THAT WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE A LOT OF CAPITAL IN THE
STREET. AND.
B. THREE PASSES EVEN MORE.
GREAT FANDOM AND I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE
PUTTING THE MONEY OUT IN WAVES.
AND GET OUT SOME MONEY EARLY AND
THEN WAIT FOR THE FEDERAL MONEY
TO COME DOWN BEFORE.
PUTTING THAT OUT HOW MUCH OF
THE STATE USED THE FUNDING HAS
ALREADY GONE OUT THIS YEAR.
.
TO DATE AND THEN WILL GO OUT OF
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS LIKE GIVE US
A SENSE OF IT THIS YEAR'S AND WE
HAVEN'T DONE A FOR THIS YEAR WE
WOULD BE W. B. BLOCK MONTH BOOK
IT WE WE WE DID ABOUT A THIRD OF
THE FUNDING ALREADY OF OUR.
STATE EST FUNNY SO INITIALLY WE
HAD ABOUT THIRTY FIVE THIRTY SIX
MILLION OFFER CC SO WE HAVE A
TWENTY FIVE MILLION MEETING IN
THE REASON WHY WE ARE SO SORRY
SINCE YOUR PROPERTY THIRTY FIVE
WE WERE BUT AT THE SIGHT SENT
TWENTY FIVE OUT OF TWENTY FIVE.
STILL REMAINS FROM THAT AND THE
REASON WHY THAT THIS IS IT ME IS
IT EARLY ON OTHERS ALSO SHIFT
FOR THOSE FOR THE FOR THOSE
GRANTEES SO THEY NEED A KIND OF
A RAMPING UP SO TO SPEAK.
AND THAT WAS WHY WAS BETTER
THIRD DOWN IN THE FIRST ROUND
AND THEN THEY GET TO SPEECH
WASN'T DO THE REMAINDER. THIS
YEAR AND NOW IT DOES OF COURSE
BEFORE S. B. TWO WITHIN THE NEXT
IT'S ANOTHER THREE TO THE NEXT
WE JUST THINK THEY'RE COMMITTING
CONDOMS OF SKILL. BUT PUTTING
THEM ALL TOGETHER FOR SOME
EXPANDED USES COUNTER JUSTIN
ERUPT. IN WHAT YEAR WAS ORIGINAL
ESG DOLLARS.
.
PUT OUT.
BUT THE FIRST THE FIRST THE
FIRST TOWARDS THAT WE MADE IRAQ
LEAVE WERE IN TWENTY SIX
SEVENTEEN.
RIGHT WITH THE BUT I'M SORRY
PROCREATIVE.
BUT WHAT WOULD YOUR THEIR
PROGRAMS ORIGINALLY I CAN KINDA.
OF THE FUNDS APPROPRIATED IN THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN BUDGET ACT FOR
TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN HOWEVER
RESOURCES FOR STAFFING WERE NOT
PROVIDED UNTIL A TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN PCP WAS
APPROVED. AND SO ON.
THE INITIAL WORDS ARE MADE IN
POLICE.
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN.
FOR. SORRY TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN FOR.
FOREIGN NINE MILLION THAT FIRST
HE SEES ME.
.
FOUR NINE MILLION OF THE THIRTY
FIVE MILLION AND SO TWENTY SIX
MILLION TO OVER MEANS BETWEEN
THE CAREER THE BUDGET YEAR.
OKAY. STARTED RICHARD NORRIS UP
IN ARE YOU IS THERE ANY PLAN TO
DISTRIBUTE MONEY REGIONALLY.
SO THAT.
REGIONS OF THE STATE CAN
COORDINATE HOW TO BEST ADDRESS
HOMELESS CRISES AS OPPOSED TO
CITY BY CITY OR COUNTY BY
COUNTY.
SURE.
WELL WE ARE PROPOSING TO DO IT
THROUGH TO THE EXISTING PROCESS
WAS GO TO CONTINUES OF CARE IN
ORDER FOR THE COTTONY BECAUSE
THOSE THE ENTITIES THAT RECEIVE
ALL THE FEDERAL FUNDING AS WELL.
UNTIL IT VARIES SOME COULD USE A
CARE ARE MULTI COUNTY IN FACT NO
ONE IS SEVEN COUNTIES UP IN THE
NORTHERN PART OF STATE RIGHT
THERE ARE SOME. THERE ARE SOME
ITS IT.
THERE ARE SOME COLLABORATIONS
ON THAT LEVEL.
THE NICE PART ABOUT THAT IS
THAT'S A TYPICALLY WHERE CITIES
AND COUNTIES ARE BOTH ENGAGED TO
THE POST IS ONE OF THE SECURE
THE COUNTY. RECEIVING THE
FUNDING.
BUT THEY DO VARY IN TERMS OF
THEIR.
TO YOUR GRAPHIC COVERAGE TO
CERTAINLY.
.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE
ANYTHING IN THE WAY WE'VE
WITHOUT WHAT IF YOU DO THAT
WOULD PRECLUDE. YOU KNOW IT MORE
REGIONAL APPROACHES BUT THE
FACTS ARE AND SOME WE CAN THINK
ABOUT AS WE.
GET TO THE FINAL CUT THE
GUIDELINES MIGHT BE INTERESTING
IT'S A PUBLIC COMMENT ON THAT
YET BUT I THINK WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT. HOMELESSNESS
DOESN'T ASSERTED STAY IN A CITY
OR A COUNTY AND GETTING WE JUST
TO WORK WITH EACH OTHER TO COURT
A RESOURCES.
BOB MIGHT MAKE SOME SENATE WE
HAVE ALLOWED IN THE PASS.
IF THE PREVIOUS DURATIONS FOR
CONTINUE TO CARE TO CUT A JOIN
UP THERE FUNDS IF THEY DECIDED
TO DO SO I THINK WE ONLY HAD
ONE.
OR TWO XR TWO TWO TWO POTENTIAL
DOT GREAT HE'S GOING UP TO DO
THAT WE PROVIDED THAT OPTION WE
HAVE PROVIDED THAT'S AN OPTION I
M. TWO FINAL QUESTIONS SO. AT
THIS MOMENT THE REALLY. THERE
ANY STATE PROGRAMS TO EXIST THAT
EXISTS TO ADDRESS CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS.
THAT.
WE CAN GET UP AND RUNNING
QUICKLY
AT THIS POINT MY UNDERSTANDING
IS WE REALLY DON'T HAVE THAT
RIGHT.
WE'D WE CERTAINLY HAVE A NAY.
ON THE NO POLITICAL PROGRAM FOR
EXAMPLE RIGHT RATING AT THAT HAS
A SPECIFIC TARGET ON CHRONICLE
WITH THIS AND WRITE LOW THIS
AUTUMN A PART OF THOSE THOSE
FUNDS HAVE BEEN BOTTLED UP IN
YEAH AND WE'RE PROBABLY.
POTENTIAL YEAR AWAY FROM BEING
ABLE TO TAP THOSE TO AGE IT FOR
ALMOST ALL OF OUR CAPITAL
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS YOU SCORED
BETTER IF YOU TARGET THE MORE
DEEPLY PRODUCT PUBLICIST SO IN
THAT WAY WE. WE INCENTIVIZE
THAT.
BUT THOSE ARE ALL ON THE
DEVELOPMENT SIDE OF THINGS THIS
IS THE ONLY PROGRAM THAT WE
ADMINISTER THAT'S KIND OF THE
NON CAPITAL.
.
OPTION FOR THE MOST PART GREAT
AND THEN A FINAL QUESTION M..
THE SP TWO ESTIMATES FOR
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN RIGHT NOW ARE
FAR LOWER THAN WHAT WE
I HOPE FOR A NO.
TO UNDER FIFTY MILLION OR MORE
OF WHAT WE HAD ANTICIPATED GET
FROM SP TWO COULD YOU OR COULD
SOMEONE EXPLAIN WHY THE
ESTIMATES ARE. HALF OF WHAT WE
HAD THOUGHT WE VOTED ON LAST
YEAR.
AND SO THE ESTIMATES STILL
REMAINS A TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION TOTAL FOR THE CALENDAR
YEAR BUT BECAUSE OF THE.
ALIGNMENT OF THE BUDGET YEAR
AND THE CALENDAR YEAR I THINK
THAT'S THAT ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE MILLION YOU OKAY SO IT IS
IT IS A COUNTER YOU.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
.
FOR OUR COLLEAGUES I THINK WE'LL
KNOW THAT.
NOT ONLY DO WITH A HOUSING
CRISIS WE'VE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
IN THE CHALLENGES. THAT WE'VE
HAD IS A STATE IS GETTING FUNDS
GETTING ENOUGH FUNDS QUICKLY
ENOUGH TO PROGRAMS AT WORK AND I
THINK.
WE.
YOU KNOW WE'RE STARTING GET
FUNDS OUT BUT BECAUSE NO PLACE
LIKE HOME MONIES HAVE BEEN HELD
UP THAT HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO GET
OUT.
WE HAVE A POT OF MONEY THAT WE
NEED TO GET OUT FASTER.
AND THAT WE HAVE THE ODYSSEY
NEED TO WRAP IT UP AND THEN WHAT
MR UPSET WAS TALKING ABOUT WAS.
A WAS HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THESE
FUNDS ARE WELL USED AND AND I
THINK ALL OF US ARE. ACUTELY.
INTERESTED IN AND SEE THE
OUTCOME OF WHERE THE
ADMINISTRATION GETS WITHOUT HOW
THE YEARS SHE PROGRAM IS CHANGED
ARE BUT. A AGAIN APPRECIATE ALL
THE THINKING THAT'S GONE INTO
THIS AND AND MR HOMESTEAD WITH
LOVE FOR. LOVE THAT INITIAL
DESCRIPTION THAT YOU YOU READ TO
US AT THE BEGINNING OF OF
EXACTLY THE CURRENT THINKING OF
OF HOW THOSE MONIES WILL BE
USED.
MR SHAPIRO.
SO I JUST WANNA.
SECOND THAT I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE THOUGHTFULNESS IT'S GONE
INTO UP PUTTING TOGETHER
SOMETHING VERY QUICKLY.
AND.
AT MY INTEREST IS.
IN INCOME AND WE LOOK AT THIS
HOMELESS ISSUE IS LOOKING AT
BEST PRACTICES WHAT'S WORKING
AND WHAT COMMUNITIES I DON'T
KNOW HOW WE GET THERE. FRANKLY
I'M BUT MAYBE IT'S AFTER A YEAR
OF PUTTING THESE FUNDS OUT THERE
WE TAKE A STEP BACK AND TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S ACTUALLY
WORKING.
.
MY OPINION LOCALLY IN MY REGION
IS THAT.
WE KEEP DOING THE SAME THING
OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND IT'S NOT
ANY MORE SUCCESSFUL THAN THE
YEAR BEFORE AND SO. ON I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT THAT LIST OF
THINGS THAT YOU WENT THROUGH
THAT I TRADED TAKE NOTES AND IF
YOU CAN PRETTY YOU KNOW PRESENT
SOMETHING THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
MORE FORMAL THAT WOULD BE MUCH
APPRECIATED THANK YOU. IN JUST A
FOLLOW UP AND ON THE STREET YOU
EARLIER TALKED ABOUT REPORTING
THAT I DO BELIEVE IT'S.
THE COUNTIES AND CITIES HAVE THE
BEST.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S BEST FOR THEIR
JURISDICTIONS BUT. AT SOME POINT
SOME REPORT BACK WAS WORKING NOT
ONE NOT WORKING LOT OF MONEY'S
GOING OUT AND WE NEVER GET.
WHAT'S AFFECTED WAS NOT THAT'S
WITH THE BIGGEST ISSUE NOT JUST
HOMELESSNESS THE MONTHS A LOT OF
PROGRAMS STATE PROGRAMS.
I DON'T THINK I AGREE COMPLETELY
WITH YOU INTENDED TO SPEAK TO
YOUR WE PUT WITH HAVING YOUR
OWN.
YOU KNOW SOME OF THESE THINGS
WITH MANY MORE THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN BEST PRACTICES THAT MAKE ME
IS THAT WE WANT TO ALLOW FOR
RIGHTS WE WANT READ AS AN OPTION
OTHER COMMUNITIES TO REPLICATE
IF THEY CAN'T. SO THERE REPORT
BACK EVERY HIT FROM THESE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ON MONEY SPENT
AND.
WITH THE PLAN WITH THAT
WE HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED ANY FUNDS
OBVIOUSLY IN THIS MANNER YET SO
WE WOULD OUTLINED IN RIGHTS
GUIDELINES WITH EXPECT
IT WOULD BE FOR.
BUT THERE WILL BE GUIDELINES
WITH THAT THERE. WE WOULD REVISE
OUR CURRENT IF YOU GOT LET'S NOT
PLY THEM TO FULFILL THESE POTS
OF MONEY SO MAYBE CALL THE NEW
SOMETHING NEW AND IN THE END
BUT.
BUT WE WOULD PUT OUT FOR THE
FRAMEWORK AYE I LAID OUT YES
PROGRAM THAT LETS AND FINALIZE
GUIDELINES AS TO KEEP THE
COMMITTEE EXPERT REVERSING WE
EXPECT THAT.
DESKTOP REPORT BACKS WE CAN LOOK
AT IT AND HE WAS BEING
EFFECTIVE.
SO.
HOW MUCH MONEY WE SPENT BY JULY?
HOW WOULD YOU SAY WE SPEND IT
WILL IT WILL GO UP BY THIS JULY
WILL BE GOTTEN AUGUST WE WEGET
THAT WE GET SO WE GET THAT WE
GET QUARTERLY REPORTS THIRTY
DAYS AFTER EACH QUARTER FROM THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE WE HAVE
EVEN? GOTTEN OUR FIRST QUARTER'S
WORTH OF OF OF FUNDS THAT WE
HOPE THAT THAT BY THE END THIS
MONTH WE WILL HAVE THAT. AND
THEN WE GET THE SECOND QUARTERS
AT THE END OF JULY WE PUT A NO
FELT PUBLIC TO ACCEPT.
SO THEY FOCUS ON A SPENDING ESG
A WILL HAPPEN WITH PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
WE WOULD AMEND OUR PROGRAM TO
ACCOMMODATE ANYTHING THAT WAS IN
THE BUDGET.
I MEAN I WAS THAT'S PENDING
LANGUAGE SO THAT'S WILL BE
STRUCTURED OUR OUR PROCESS SO IT
FOLLOWS THE PATH TO THE STATE
BUDGET SO ANY FINALIZATION WE
COULD INCORPORATE.
A CHANGES THAT WERE MADE.
I PRESIDENT THAT'S NOT NO.
IF I CAN SPEAK TO THE TRAILER
BILL WE BELIEVE THAT THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY PROPOSED IS IN LINE
WITH THE.
THE MORE EXPANDED YES SHE
FRAMEWORK THAT WAS SPOKEN ABOUT
TODAY.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BECAUSE AN
ESTIMATE OF THE REVENUES FROM S.
B. TO.
ASIDE MISTER I I JUST WANNA
DRILL DOWN A LITTLE BIT OF THIS
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS BECAUSE THAT THE
ANALYSIS FROM THE COMMITTEE
SAID.
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
ESTIMATED THE FEE WILL RAISE
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE MILLION AND.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SO THAT'S NOT A
CALENDAR YEAR.
QUESTION IT'S A IT'S OF FISCAL
YEAR QUESTIONS A CAN YOU
ELABORATE BECAUSE IT LOOKS AS IF
FOR ONLY RAISING HALF THE MONEY
WHAT WE EXPECTED FOR THIS YEAR
SHORT FIFTIES WERE FIRST
COLLECTED ON JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND SO FOR THE
CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
.
THE QUESTIONS THAT ARE DEPOSITED
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
ACCOUNT FOR HALF OF THE TOTAL
REVENUE.
OF A FISCAL YEAR BASIS.
I SEE OKAY THIS IS THIS I GOT IT
OKAY SO YOU'RE EXPECTED TO BE ON
TRACK WITH WHAT WE ALL EXPECTED
OF A QUARTER OF THE TWO FIFTY.
MILLION EVERY EVERY FISCAL YEAR
BASED ON SB TWO FUNDS
OUR ESTIMATES ARE NOT CHANGED
OKAY WE DON'T WE HAVE COLLECTED
EVEN THE FIRST QUARTER'S REVENUE
YEAH. THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO.
MICHAEL HAD OPEN UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT ANYONE WISH TO SPEAK ON
THIS ITEM.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARONREPORT
WITH THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
AND WE TO APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT AGE CITY HAS DONE ON THIS
ISSUE. AYE WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS
WITH THE MONEY GOING THROUGH THE
EMERGENCY SOLUTIONS GRANT
PROGRAM.
WE HAVE.
HEARD BASICALLY THAT
PRELIMINARY OF FINDINGS THAT
WE'VE SEEN SO FAR ON RAPIDLY
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA HAVE NOT
SHOWN GREAT SUCCESS FOR THIS
INTERVENTION.
IN FACT THREE QUARTERS OF OUR
STATES HOMELESS POPULATION ARE
SINGLE ADULTS.
AND FOR THAT POPULATION RAPIDLY
HOUSING HAS NOT PRUNED PROVEN TO
BE SUCCESSFUL GENERALLY THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND UP HITTING A
CLIFF AT SOME POINT WHERE THAT
RENTAL ASSISTANCE ENDS AND
THEIR.
CYCLING BACK INTO HOMELESSNESS
I'LL BE THINK THAT PUTTING THE
MONEY INTO ESG WILL JUST FURTHER
THE CYCLE AND OF NOT GO TOWARD
PROVEN METHODS ON IT HAVE
RAPIDLY HOUSING IS ACTUALLY NOT
YET IN EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE.
AND.
WE DO THINK THAT THE MONEY
SHOULD NOT GO BY FORMULA BUT
SHOULD GO TO CITIES AND COUNTIES
THAT APPLY AND SHOW THAT THEY
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO. I USE THE
MONEY ALLOCATED QUICKLY TO GET
PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS QUICKLY.
TOWARD THAT END WE DO THINK THAT
THE HOUSING FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM WHICH AGE
CITY IS ALSO IMPLEMENTING THIS
YEAR. HAS A MORE TARGETED
POPULATION TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS WE HAVE FORTY TWO
PERCENT OF THE NATION'S CHRONIC
HOMELESS POPULATION. IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THERE AREN'T TOO A MISTER
CHOOSE QUESTION THERE AREN'T ANY
SIGNIFICANT. OF PROGRAMS THAT
ARE RIGHT NOW ADDRESSING THE
SPECIFIC NEEDS OF THOUGHT
POPULATION SO WE DO THINK. WHILE
IT IS EASIER TO IMPLEMENT.
OF RAPID RE HOUSING WE DO THINK
THAT IN GENERAL THIS PROGRAM
THIS SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY
SHOULD BE GOING TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF POPULATIONS MOST
VULNERABLE.
AND OF WHO NEEDS RENTS LONGER
TERM RENTAL ASSISTANCE.
BOB WE ALSO KNOW THAT.
THE HOMELESS CONTINUUM'S OF
CARE THAT GET ESG ARE NOT GOING
TO BE GETTING ANY ALLOCATIONS OF
FUNDING IN THE FUTURE SP TWO
YEARS SO.
S. B. TWO ALLOCATIONS FOR YEAR
TWO AND BEYOND. WILL NOT GO TO
HOMELESS CEO SEES THEY WILL GO
TO CITIES AND COUNTIES AND FOR
US THAT'S ANOTHER REASON WHY WE
WANT TO SEE THOSE ENTITIES
GETTING THE FIRST YEAR FUNDING
SO THAT THEY CAN SUSTAIN SOME OF
THESE PROGRAMS IF THEY CHOOSE TO
DO SO. IN FUTURE YEARS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT YOU.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FIRSTLY WE REALLY
WANT TO THANK AGE CD FOR OUR
RECENT MEETING AND FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS AROUND SP TWO
IMPLEMENTATION INCLUDING. THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
I WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON.
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
WORK OUT SOME OF OUR CONCERNS AS
WELL AS WITH THE COMMITTEE.
OUR CONCERNED SPECIFICALLY ARE
THAT SUMMER MEDINA COUNTY HAS
HISTORICALLY INVESTED A LOT OF
THEIR OWN RESOURCES AND TO.
REDUCING OUR HOMELESS POPULATION
WHICH UNDER THIS FORMULA AND I
CAN'T COMMENT ON THE EXPANDED
FORMULA. BUT UNDER THE CURRENT
FORMULA THE WOULD DISADVANTAGE
US AND SO WE ARE HOPING TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS ON THE
ISSUE.
WHEN YOU.
HEY CHRIS MARTIN WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA.
WE WHERE IT'S OF ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS ON THE ORIGINAL SB TO
BALANCE OF COURSE WANT TO SEE
THESE FUNDS. USING THOSE
MEANINGFUL WAY.
AND AS SHARON MENTIONED.
WE ARE UNDER ESG THE FUNDS WILL
GO TO THE LOCAL CEO SEES AND.
UNDER S. B. TO THE.
ELIGIBLE OR WHO WILL BE
RECEIVING THE FUNDS AT THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES AND SO WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THEM A MORE
SUSTAINABLE PROGRAM CREATED.
TO UTILIZE THE THE FUTURE FUNDS
ARE MEN AND ALSO WOULD SUPPORT
PUTTING THE FUNDS AND.
AB SEVENTY FOUR AS MENTIONED
THE HOUSING FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA WHICH LOOKS MORE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS AND.
WOULD ACCOMPLISH A LOT MORE OF
OUR GOALS.
IF YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN REYES
FAMILY DATING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY
EIGHT OF CALIFORNIA'S COUNTIES
THANK YOU AGAIN. WE AGREE
STRONGLY WITH EACH CD'S GOALS
AND GETTING THE MONEY OUT AS
FAST AS POSSIBLE. ON AND MAKING
THEM DOLLARS AS FLEXIBLE AS
POSSIBLE THIS IS THE FIRST WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT THAT YES G. MODEL.
SO WE'LL HAVE TO EVALUATE THAT
BUT.
WHAT WE WANT TO STRONGLY SAY IS
THAT?
THE FLEXIBILITY IS GOING TO BE
THE KEY FOR COUNTIES AND CITIES
TO RECEIVE THE FUNDING.
OUTCOMES WE THINK ARE
REASONABLE THING ON TASK FOR FOR
THIS FUNDING BECAUSE ONE TIME
FUNDING WERE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO MAKE THE FUNDING GO
AS FAR AS IT CAN HOW HOW CAN WE
MAKE AN IMPACT WITH. THIS ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR WHICH WERE VERY
APPRECIATIVE I WANNA THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME ON THIS ISSUE AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
EIGHT CITY FURTHER. THANK YOU.
MERLIN CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT.
WE KNOW SADDAM OPEN.
SMALLER NEXT AUTOMATION EVER TO
HOUSING FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
FUTURE BILLING WHICH.
OKAY SO ALL THE TOUGH THE
DISCUSSION.
AS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT TO TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS AB SEVENTY FOUR
DIRECTS DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO
REDEPLOY FEDERAL FUNDS RECEIVED
FROM THE NATIONAL HOUSING TRUST
FUND.
TO ASSIST HOMELESS CALIFORNIANS.
ACCORDINGLY THE DEPARTMENT
PROPOSES TO REDESIGN THE
NATIONAL HOUSING TRUST FUND
PROGRAM. TO ADDRESS THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
SPECIFICALLY EACH CD REQUESTS
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN.
NINE HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY.
FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS ONGOING
FROM THE FEDERAL TRUST FUND TO
IMPLEMENT CHAPTER SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN STATUTES OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. AB SEVENTY FOUR.
THIS REQUEST INCLUDES AUTHORITY
FOR TWO POSITIONS.
AN INTER AGENCY AGREEMENT WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
AND A CONTRACT WITH AN
INDEPENDENT EVALUATOR IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY.
EACH CITY ALSO REQUEST TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO ESTABLISH
AUTHORITY TO COLLECT MONITORING
FEES.
AND DEPOSIT THE FEES INTO THE
HOUSING REHABILITATION LOAN
FUND.
THANK YOU HELLO.
FINANCE.
I HAVE A QUESTION.
POSITION EASY STARTED TO RESIGN
THE IN HDF PER A. B. SEVENTY
FOUR.
OUGHT NOT NOT COMPLETELY YET
RIGHT BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
POSITIONS OR THE THE STAFF
CAPACITY BY WHICH TO DO THAT BUT
WE HAVE POLICY HAS MATERNAL
CONVERSATIONS ON A WHAT.
YOU WANT SIX DEATHS ONBOARD
HELENAE THINK WE'LL TAKE THEIR
ESTIMATED TIMELINE.
WERE YOU LOOKING AT I WOULD YOU
ARE PLAN WOULD BE TO DEPLOY NO
FOR NEXT SOMETIME NEXT YEAR.
FIRST QUARTER IN THE NEXT YEAR.
WHAT PART OF THE LEGISLATION
REQUIRES THAT WE PUT SOMETHING
IN OUR?
HUD ALLOCATION PLAN THAT THIS
YEAR SO WE WILL BE HAVING PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE SUMMER RELATIVE
TO THE ALLOCATION PLAN
REQUIREMENT AND THEN WE WILL BE
WORKING ON GUIDELINES THROUGH
THE REST OF THE YEAR WITH A NO
FRIEND TO SPEEDED SOMETIME EARLY
IN. TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN OKAY
AND HOW LONG THE PROGRAM BEFORE
IN FUTURE YEARS.
SHOULD THE FEDERAL FUNDS
DISAPPEAR.
OUR OTHER THAN THE FEDERAL FUNDS
ARE NO CURRENT FUNDS IDENTIFIED
FOR THE.
THANK YOU.
CHIU.
WHEN HE FIRST SAID START AGAIN
WITH A THANK YOU TO.
FOR SIGNING THIS BILL WHICH
WHICH I'D AUTHORED I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
SUPPORT AND.
ALSO THINK THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT JUST SPOKEN PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR A FOR A PUSHING THIS VISION
OF OF OF OF A BILL THAT FOCUSES
ON HOUSING FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA.
COUPLE QUESTIONS HOW MUCH DID
WE GET.
IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN FROM THE
NATIONAL HOUSING TRUST FUND
WOODY WAS A CITY ESTIMATING
BURGUNDY RECEIVING. NECK AND OF
THIS COMING YEAR AND NEXT YEAR
IS TO GET A SENSE OF.
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDS THE SIZE OF
THE PROGRAM.
TWENTY ONE MILLION FOR THIS
YEAR.
UNCLEAR LIKE WITH THAT WOULD BE
THE AMOUNT EVERY YEAR BUT.
.
BUT I DON'T THINK SO LITTLE
UNPREDICTABLE THESE DAYS OF THE
FAT IS BUT BUT IF ALL GOES ON
TRACK BASED ON PAST HISTORY
YOU'RE THINKING IN THE TWENTIES
TO THIRTIES IS AT. AN ESTIMATE.
RIGHT WE DO NOT.
AND I THINK FINANCE HAS SUCH A
TEST.
SIR ARE YOU WANTED FALL WITH THE
NUMBERS THAT I HAD.
THE FEDERAL GRANT AMOUNT WAS
TEN POINT ONE MILLION IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AT A FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY SIXTEEN. AND TWENTY THREE
POINT TWO MILLION AND. FEDERAL
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO
TWENTY THREE POINT. TWENTY THREE
POINT TWO MILLION.
IT WAS THAT.
THE REASON FOR THE INCREASES.
AND FROM FROM YEAR TO YEAR WAS
AT THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAD.
I KNOW THIS PROGRAMS ACTUALLY
NOT FUNDED ON THE DISCRETIONARY
OVER THE FEDERAL BUDGET AND A
DIRECTLY BY THE GOVERNMENT
SPONSORED ENTITIES FANNIE MAE
AND FREDDIE MAC. AND SO THEIR
DEPOSITS OF INCREASED GOTCHA
* GIVEN THAT. A CITY IS
REQUIRED TO ESTABLISH ITS
PROGRAM BY THE FIRST OF TWENTY
NINETEEN DO YOU FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH THE STAFFING LEVEL YOU'LL
BE ON TRACK TO DOING THAT.
YES WE FEEL VERY CONFIDENT OKAY.
TOM WILL I HAVE TO SAY WHEN I
READ THE ANALYSIS ON THIS AYE
AYE OF COURSE ONE SEE THIS
PROGRAM STEPPED UP AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE IN AND WHAT WAS
PROPOSED.
.
I WASN'T SURE IF THAT WAS GONNA
BE THE CASE AND AND I'M
WONDERING IF.
IF EIGHT CD HAVE RECEIVED NEWER
DOLLARS FROM SP TWO OR THE
GENERAL FUND WOULD YOU HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO TO DO MORE.
YOU'RE BASICALLY SAYING THIS IS
A LEVEL THAT THAT.
E. OF STAFFING THAT YOU NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE DOLLARS THAT
WERE DISSIPATING WILL BE WELL
SPENT.
YEAH I DON'T THINK WHICH IS OUR
TIMELINE IN WOULD BUILD OFFER NO
FOR.
.
BUT I THINK WE'VE ALSO
CALCULATED.
STAFFING NEEDS BASED ON SP TO
FROM WHEN WE USE THE SG
PROGRAMMERS ARE RESOURCE BUT I
I'M NOT SURE THE RIBBING MUCH
DIFFERENT SO IT TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT S. B.
TWO DOLLARS. REVA ESTIMATED
STAFFING NEEDS FOR SP TWO FUNDS
AS A COMMON.
OKAY SO STAFF THERE WOULD IT
AFTER BE THERE DOVER IF THAT WAS
DESIGNED TO BEFORE. OKAY AND
THEN M. I PICKED IT UP A FULL
QUESTION RELATED TO SOME OF THE
PUBLIC COMMENT THAT WE HEARD
FROM SHALL REPORT. OF.
GIVEN THE SHORTCOMINGS OF THE
CURRENT ESG PROGRAM.
FOCUSED ON RAPIDLY HOUSING
WHICH OBVIOUSLY ONLY FOCUSES ON
A SUB.
OF
FOLKS ARE HOMELESS DO YOU FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT THE EXPANSION
THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING IS GOING
TO CAPTURE. A THE THE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS POPULATION
THAT REALLY HAS. THE HEART OF OF
WHO WERE TRYING TO SOLVE FOR.
YEAH I I ACTUALLY WOULDN'T SAY
THIS IS THE IF YOU PROGRAM AT
ALL RIGHT WE ARE USING SOME OF
THAT ABOUT THE OTHER BASELINE
FOR CONTINUITY FOR YOU KNOW
RECIPIENTS IN THE SORT OF THINGS
BUT TERMS THE EXPANDED USES
THERE SO THERE SO MUCH BROADER.
THAN THAT WHAT WE WERE ABLE TO
DO BEFORE THAT I WOULDN'T
CHARACTERIZE WHAT WE'RE DOING
THE FOR EVEN AS YES TO EITHER
SOME YES YOU LIKE PROVISIONS
RIGHT YOU CAN STILL FUND
NAVIGATION TYPESETTERS YOU COULD
STILL DO A RAPPER HOUSING MODEL
IF YOU DETERMINE THAT WAS BEST
FOR YOUR. COMMUNITY BUT THERE'S
A NUMBER OF OTHER USES RIGHT
THAT THAT GO WELL BEYOND.
WHAT WE CURRENTLY OR PREVIOUSLY
WERE ABLE TO FUND AND SO WHILE
WE USE THAT AS A WAY TO?
MOVE FORWARD RIGHT IN TERMS OF
HELPING TO HAVE CONTINUITY FOR
OUR GRANTEES THEIR COMMUNITIES.
I DON'T THINK IT'S PROBABLY
ACTOR TO SIT THIS ESP MOVING
FORWARD RIGHT THIS IS TAKING
SOME OF THE THINGS FROM ESPN
EXPANDING SIGNIFICANTLY BASED ON
THE. THE DEFICIENCIES THAT WERE
THERE THAT WE HEARD FROM AYE
ADVOCATES AND AND THE
COMMUNITIES AS WELL GOTTA GET
YOU YOU REFER TO AN EXPANDED
YESTERDAY SO I I'M HEARING YOU
NOW SO ESSENTIALLY SOMETHING
THAT'S BROADER THAT ADDRESSES.
THE MULTIPLICITY OF OF
CHALLENGES THAT WERE SEEN WITH
YEAH I MEANIF IT HURTS A GUY I
DON'T KNOW.
BUT CERTAINLY IT THAT WE HOPE
IT WILL ALLOW TO GET AT SOME OF
THOSE USES ALL OF US THAT WILL
BE AT THE DISCRETION TO SOME
DEGREE OF THE THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
INTO TO DETERMINE THEIR NEED.
BUT.
BUT WE DO THINK THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY IS THERE TO TO REACH
MUCH DEEPER.
ANSWER MUCH BROADER BROADER
SWATH THAT IS GOOD TO HEAR. I'M.
ASSUMING THIS PROGRAM IS TO
ESTABLISH BY GENDER FIRST OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WHEN WITH THE
FIRST NO FOR. LIKELY GO OUT.
I THINK WE ANTICIPATE THAT FIRST
QUARTER TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
GREAT THANK YOU.
EXCUSE ME WITH POSITIONS
INCLUDED IN THE FIRST PHASE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
CHOI.
WHAT WITH THE ALL HOME ALL
AVAILABLE OR NEW FUNDING SOURCES
FOR HOMELESS ARE?
?
CAN YOU PROJECT AFTER CERTAIN
NUMBER BE YOUR SET UP TO YOUR SO
THREE YEARS FIVE YEARS.
WITH BE UP CONTINUOUS OR
REVENUE.
HOW MUCH HOMELESSNESS?
SITUATION OR BE SELF.
I CAN'T.
I'VE THIS IS ONE TIME FUNDING
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF
S. B. TOO SO WE DON'T HAVE AN
ONGOING SOURCE OBVIOUSLY
JURISDICTION CONNECTED TO USE
SOME OF THEIR. ONGOING SP TWO
DOLLARS FOR HOMELESS USES OR OR
OTHER USES AROUND FOR A HOUSING.
BUT NO I CAN'T MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION OBVIOUSLY GETTING
AT SOME OF THE DATA PIECES THE
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT WE'D LIKE TO
SEE WHAT THIS FUND WILL MAYBE
PAINT A BETTER PICTURE CAN YOU
SAY THIS IS A DROP IN THE BUCKET
OVER RICE HAS SUBSTANTIAL LA
AMOUNT. TO.
WAS SITUATION WOULD BE IMPROVED.
CERTAINLY OUR HOPE IS THAT THE
SITUATION BE PREVENT THINK WE
ALL KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT OF A
LOT MORE RESOURCES NEEDED IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
PUBLIC THAT'S WHY YOU SEE A
BOND ON THE BALLOT THIS YEAR.
A LOT OF JURISDICTIONS PUTTING
LOCAL BOND MEASURES ON THE
BALLOT.
PUTTING THEIR OWN DOLLARS AND
SO YEAH THIS THIS ALONE WILL NOT
WILL NOT SOLVE SOLVE THE PROBLEM
WE DO HOPE THAT THE. THE
REDESIGN WILL WILL HOPEFULLY
LEVERAGE AND AUGMENT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT ARE WORKING.
GOING BACK TO S. B. TO WRAP IN
YOU.
.
IT WAS SUGGESTED TO EVENLY
DIVIDED UP.
HER FIRST HELPFUL WHEN YOU GO
INTO.
THE CITY CENTER COUNTY IS SO
POOR THEY ARE. UP.
THE LAND USE UPDATE YEAH SO
THAT'LL AND AND THAT THAT NOSSO
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNTS TO HALF.
ON THE OTHER ONE IS SO TO HELP
BALK AT THE HOME AS SICK
INDIVIDUAL SO INDIVIDUALS MEANS
THAT THE W. TWO WEEK GAVE THE
MONEY DIRECTLY TO THEM. OR OR OR
PROGRAMS THAT THE CITIES AND THE
COUNTIES TO WOULD HAVE TO.
COMPETE INTO YOU KNOW EARNED
THAT.
ON A QUICK BASIS PROPOSAL THAT
WE'VE LAID OUT WE WE DON'T DO DO
DIRECT DISTRIBUTION IT'S
INDIVIDUALS WE PROVIDE THEM TO
THE GOVERNOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
DEVELOPERS ON THIS CASE.
POTENTIALLY CONTINUES OF CARE
WHICH ARE.
COLLABORATIONS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
THE LIKE AND THEN THEY WOULD
MAKE THE DETERMINATION ON WHAT
PROGRAMS TO FUND WITH THIS KIND
OF BLOCK GRANT FUNDS.
SO.
WE DON'T PROVIDE DIRECT
ASSISTANCE INDIVIDUALS BUT.
POTENTIALLY PROGRAMS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
OKAY BUT THE.
DAY HALF OF THE OF REVENUE THAT
THOSE. YOU HAVE RECEIVED BUT DO
YOU GOT BE A FIRST OUT THIS YEAR
SO POINT QUARTERLY REVENUE WE
HAVE NOT RECEIVED ANY REVENUE.
BECAUSE OF THAT IT IS SENATE ON
QUARTERLY BASIS ARE AS SAW.
END OF MARCH WAS THE FIRST WE
GET A VERY HIGH CONTROLLERS OFF
IF THEY MONEY BECAUSE THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AND WE
EXPECT A THIRTY DAYS AFTER EACH
QUARTER TO BE REMITTED LESLIE IT
ANNOYS LATIN LIKE RIGHT NOW.
BUT EVENTUALLY IT'LL BE TWENTY
OF FIFTY EIGHT THE MILLION
DOLLARS TORTILLA.
ARE.
WHAT DOT?
WELL WELL THOUGHT A LOT ABOUT.
FEED YOUR WILL ARE BASED UPON
YOU ONLY HAVE HALF OF DHEA
REVENUE IS SAID THOUGHT IT HAS
TO BE HAVE.
DOES IT HAVE TO BE REVISED.
I'M NOT SURE I UNDERSTOOD YOUR
QUESTION.
WE WILL HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF
IT THE OTHER THE FIRST QUARTER'S
REVENUE WHAT WHAT WOULD BE ON
TRACK OF EACH QUARTER'S REVENUE
WILL BE DIFFERENT FROM YOUR TWO
YEAR IT IS A.
FUNDING SOURCE THAT YOU
ESTIMATED.
DE THAT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS SO AND OR YOU
KNOW YOU'RE RIGHT BECAUSE IT
DOES THE JOB BASED BASED UPON SO
FAR REVENUE WHAT THAT THIS IS
ACCURATE FEATURE.
NOW WOULD WE TOUCHED UPON ONE OF
ALL WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE FIRST
QUARTER'S REVENUES SO WE CAN'T
DO ANY EXTRAPOLATION AT THIS
TIME. SUCKING REPORT TO US BUT
THE RHETORIC MAY REVISE MAY
REVISE WHAT CAME BACK YEAH WE
WOULD KNOW THE FIRST QUARTER'S
REVENUE WILL. BE GREAT.
FROM THERE YOU WOULD HAVE BAD
IDEA HAS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY.
WE KNOW SADDAM OPEN.
SO THANK YOU.
THERE'S NO PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS I BELIEVE.
OTHER IS I'M SORRY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SHARON REPORT WITH
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING JUST WANNA SUPPORT EIGHT
CITIES REQUEST FOR STAFFING.
I'VE FOR THE HOUSING FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA PROGRAM AND
DOVE THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU
IS WELL FOR AUTHORING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
YOU.
CHRIS MARTIN WITH HOUSING FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA.
AS CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
JUST WHEN I THINK OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND SUPPORT.
THE STAFFING LEVELS FOR THIS.
THANK YOU.
RURAL OR ITS ITEM ISSUE NUMBER
THREE LONG TERM MONITORING IN
DEFAULT RESERVES.
EACH CITY ADMINISTERS PROGRAMS
THAT PROVIDE GRANTS AND LOANS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NONPROFITS AND
STAKEHOLDERS.
TO CREATE RENTAL AND HOME
OWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES.
THROUGH LONG TERM MONITORING.
EACH C. D. ENSURES THAT RENTAL
DEVELOPMENTS CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND
THAT PROJECTS REMAIN WELL
MAINTAINED AND FINANCIALLY
SOUND.
EACH CITY FUNDS ITS LONG TERM
MONITORING BY REQUIRING AND THE
ANNUAL POINT FOUR TWO PERCENT
INTEREST PAYMENT ON THE LOAN
PRINCIPAL.
S. SETS ASIDE UP TO FOUR PERCENT
OF FUNDS APPROPRIATED TO CURE
ORDER AVERT POTENTIAL DEFAULTS
OVER THE FIFTY FIVE YEAR LIFE OF
EACH LOAN.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT PROPOSES
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
STREAMLINE THE ADMINISTRATION OF
LONG TERM MONITORING. PROVIDE
CONSISTENCY ACROSS ALL RENTAL
PROGRAMS AND DECREASE THE RISK
OF DEFAULT OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS.
BY AUTHORIZING THAT ONE. EIGHT
H. S. C..
V. H.
P. P. M. TOT PROGRAMS BE
AUTHORIZED TO COLLECT AND
DEPOSIT POINT FOUR TWO PERCENT
MONITORING FEE IN TO FIND NINE
TWO NINE.
FOUR FIFTY FIVE YEAR MONITORING
AND THAT THESE PROGRAMS
ESTABLISHED TO FOLLOW RESERVE
ACCOUNTS.
IN TO EACH CITY REQUEST THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS
FROM THE HOUSING REHABILITATION
LOAN FUND FUND NINE TWO NINE.
TO ESTABLISH TWO POSITIONS TO OR
WORD FUNDS PREVIOUSLY HELD IN
DEFAULT RESERVES.
AND TWO POSITIONS FOR LONG TERM
MONITORING FOUR E. CHESSIE AND
V. HHT.
THE SIXTEEN PROGRAMS WAS
CONSIDERED AN ADEQUATE AMOUNT OF
DEFAULT RESERVE.
RESEARCH INDICATES THAT ONE AND
A HALF PERCENT OF OUTSTANDING
LOANS REFLECTS AN APPROPRIATE
DEFAULT RESERVE BALLOTS WILL
PULLING LONG TERM
MONITORING RESOURCES RESULT IN
ONE PROGRAM. SUBSIDIZING
ANOTHER.
KNOW. WHAT IT DOES DO IS IT
PROVIDES THE OPPORTUNITY TO?
?
UC'S FUNDS TO MITIGATE THE RISK
OF DEFAULT ACROSS PROGRAMS BUT
ONE PROGRAM AT EACH PROGRAM WILL
WILL NOT BE USED TO SUBSIDIZE
ANOTHER PROGRAM.
LL.
FINANCE.
NICHOLAS IN THE COMMITTEE.
A PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO LIST
NEXT TAKE OF ISSUE NUMBER FOR
VETERANS HOUSING HOMELESS
PREVENTION PROGRAM.
PROPOSITION FORTY ONE CHAPTER
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN STATUTES OF
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN. WAS
PASSED BY VOTERS TO RESTRUCTURE
THE VETERANS BOND ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT.
AUTHORIZING SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN EXISTING BOND
AUTHORITY TO FUND HOUSING
PROGRAMS AND OPPORTUNITIES TO
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
HAS WORKED TOGETHER TO EXPLORE
DIFFERENT MODELS. THAT INCLUDE
CAPITAL FUNDING TO CONSTRUCT
HOUSING PROJECTS AND PROVIDE
OPERATING OR RENTAL SUBSIDIES TO
REDUCE RENTS TO A LEVEL
AFFORDABLE. TO EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME AND HOMELESS VETERANS.
EACH CD REQUESTS A BASELINE
BUDGET INCREASE OF THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
AND THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ONGOING FOR TO
NEW POSITIONS TO EXECUTE LONG
CLOSINGS AND MITIGATE LITIGATION
COSTS. RELATED TO THE VETERANS
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION PROGRAM.
OIL.
FINANCE.
YES WE JUST HAVE A TECHNICAL.
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE CHANGE
THAT I MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY FOR
BOTH THIS VCP ON THE HOUSING
PACKAGE THAT WE'VE SHARED WITH
YOUR STAFF AND BELIAU. THANK YOU
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
ENTER THE PUBLIC WHICH IS BIG ON
THE SIDE OF.
GOOD RECOMMENDATIONS OLD OPUS
WILL HOLD OPEN.
NEXT ITEM ISSUE NUMBER FIVE A
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT BLOCK
GRANT PROGRAM WE DESIGN UPDATE.
SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND GIVE HER A
BRIEF UPDATE ON THIS.
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT BLOCK
GRANT REDESIGN EFFORTS.
AS YOU ARE AWARE OF THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR ASKED US
TO DO A NUMBER OF THINGS
RELATIVE TO THIS PROGRAM.
AND WE'D LIKE TO REPORT THAT WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING SINCE LAST
SUMMER TO IT.
DRESSED THE CONCERNS EXPRESSED
INTERNALLY WITHIN OUR OWN
DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS THOSE
RAISED BY STAKEHOLDERS.
HUGS ARE FEDERAL PARTNER AND
AND YOU THE LEGISLATURE.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY ON PROGRAM
REDESIGN WITH A GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS REPRESENTING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS CONSULTANTS.
AND ASSOCIATIONS SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR LOCAL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES AND THE ROLE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
AS WELL AS ROBUST PARTICIPATION
FROM LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND
REPRESENTATIVES FROM OUR AGENCY
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
JUST AS A REMINDER TO CRITICAL
COMPONENTS OF THE REDESIGN HAVE
BEEN TO ENSURE THAT EACH CD KIND
OF FISH ONLY ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM IN A WAY. THAT
EFFECTIVELY SERVES CALIFORNIA
SMALL IN RULE JURISDICTIONS
WITHIN EXISTING RESOURCES.
AND TO MODIFY THE PROGRAM DESIGN
AND OPERATIONS TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE A VIABLE PROGRAM THAT MEETS
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS. NOW AND
INTO THE FUTURE.
ASPART OF THE REDESIGN PROCESS
WE'VE ESTABLISHED THREE
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS THAT ARE
FOCUSED ON ADDRESSING THE
CONCERNS AND OFFERING SOLUTIONS
AND THREE PROGRAM AREAS
INCREASING THE CBG EXPENDITURE
RATE WHICH IS A BEEN AMONG THE
LOWEST IN THE COUNTRY.
DECREASING OUR UNSPENT PROGRAM
INCOME WHICH HAD REQUIRES BE
SPENT BY LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
PRIOR TO RECEIVING GRANT
DOLLARS.
AND STRATEGIES TO SUPPORT AND
ENCOURAGE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
I ALSO IS PART OF THESE REDESIGN
ACTIVITIES HAD A EACH CD EXCUSE
ME HAS BEEN LOOKING INTERNALLY
AT ITS OPERATIONAL.
.
PROCESSES AND PROCEDURES AND
MAKING GREAT STRIDES TO IMPROVE
THESE INCLUDING THE
CONSOLIDATION RECENTLY OF TWO
SECTIONS INTO ONE. HAS A GRANT
MANAGEMENT FUNCTION AND HAVING
MORE STAFF.
DIRECTLY DEDICATED TO THE CD
BGP PROGRAM. THE INITIATION OF
EXTENSIVE BUSINESS PROCESS
IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS FOR SEE TO
BE OPERATE OPERATIONS UPDATES
TO.
MANY OF OUR PROCESSES AND
PROCEDURES CONTINUE DATA CLEAN
UP WEBSITE UPDATES AND
IMPROVEMENTS AND INCREASED
REPORTING TO HUD.
THE REDESIGN WE THINK WILL
ALLOW US TO TO ALSO ADDRESS WHAT
WE RECEIVED A MONITORING WATER
FROM HUD.
RECENTLY THERE WAS A VISIT IN
NOVEMBER AND THEY'VE SUBMITTED A
LETTER TO US WITH A NUMBER OF
FINDINGS AND CONCERNS. AND WE
THINK THAT THOSE FINDINGS AND
CONCERNS ARE IN LINE WITH THE
WORK THAT IS ALREADY UNDER WAY
WITH THE CVG PROGRAM.
AND THOSE FINDINGS INCLUDE
INADEQUATE OVERSIGHT REPORTING
AN EXPENDITURE OF PROGRAM
INCOME.
FIVE TIMELY DISTRIBUTION OF OF
FUNDS AND.
THE NEED TO CONTINUE TO UPDATE.
AND MEET VARIOUS FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS.
AND THEN PROBABLY MOST
IMPORTANTLY FOR HUD IS THAT WE
NEED TO INCREASE OUR MONITORING
OF GRANTEES.
THESE CONCERNS WERE NOT
UNEXPECTED I HAD SHARED THEIR
CONCERNS DURING THE MONITORING
VISIT WE'VE BEEN KEEPING THE
STAKEHOLDERS SURPRISE THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS.
AND IT WAS EXTENSIVELY DISCUSSED
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS IN MARCH.
WE'RE WELL ON OUR WAY TO A
MEETING.
THE INITIAL REQUIREMENTS OF THE
MONITORING LETTER INCLUDING
SUBMITTING A RESPONSE TO HIDE
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS.
AND DEVELOPING A MANAGEMENT
PLAN TO ADDRESS THE THE FINDINGS
OVER A FIFTEEN YEAR PERIOD. I AM
I DO WANNA ACKNOWLEDGED ANYBODY
FOOT WHO HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
IN LEADING THE CBG REDESIGN
PROCESS AND WORKING WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS.
WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT WERE I'M SET FORTH
FOR US TO ACCOMPLISH IN SP ONE
OH SIX.
AND WE'RE ON OUR WAY TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE YOU THE REPORT THAT
IS DUE ON JUNE THIRTIETH.
HOW HE PROPOSED LIMIT THE
CURRENT BACKLOG?
EXCUSE ME ALLEY PROPOSED TO
ELIMINATE THE CURRENT BACKLOG.
WELL PART OF THAT WILL BE
THROUGH THE REDESIGN PROCESS
WHERE WE'RE LOOKING AT WAYS TO.
ENCOURAGE THE EXPENDITURE OF
PROGRAM INCOME.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE BIG
ISSUES THAT IS ON THE THE TABLE
FOR THE THE CBG REDESIGN.
WORKING GROUP.
AND ALSO ONE MORE QUESTION.
I'M SORRY GO AHEAD.
DO YOU HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS THE FEDERAL CONCERNS.
PART OF THERE HAD MONITORING
WATER IS ALSO PROPOSING THAT HAD
WILL BE PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SO WE THINK THROUGH
THE COMBINATION OF OUR EXISTING
RESOURCES THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT HAD WILL BE
PROVIDING. AND SOME SHORT TERM
REDIRECTION OF SOME OF OUR STAFF
WE BELIEVE THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
THE FINDINGS WITHIN THE FIFTEEN
MONTH PERIOD.
I'M A STAFFER DEDICATED THIS
PROGRAM. ELEVEN OF.
A QUESTION COMMITTEE. OF.
COUPLE QUESTIONS FIRST OF ALL
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU
GUYS ARE DOING ON THIS BECAUSE.
CBG HAS BEEN A BEEN OF A MOVING
TARGET IN IN RECENT YEARS.
OF FIRST QUESTION IS WHAT SORT
OF THINGS ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT
TO HELP SMALLER CITIES AND
COUNTIES ACCESS
FUNDS I KNOW. OUR COLLEAGUE AND
THIS COMING YEAR IS NOT HERE BUT
I'LL ASK A QUESTION HER STEAD I
KNOW IT'S A QUESTION THAT COMES
UP A LOT FOR MORE SMALLER
JURISDICTIONS.
THANKS AGAIN GINNY PUTTY FIGHT
WITH THAT THE DIVISION OF
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE EIGHT CD.
OF WE ONE OF THE REASONS THAT WE
WANTED TO HAVE SOME OF OUR
ASSOCIATIONS AS PARTNERS IN THE
REDESIGN EFFORT. WAS TO WORK
WITH AND THROUGH THEM TO REALLY
EXPAND THE AMOUNT OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
KNOWING THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES OURSELVES WITHIN EACH
C. D.. TO HONOR AROUND REALLY
REACH OUT ENGAGE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AS MUCH AS WE
WOULD LIKE BUT I THINK THROUGH
THE REDESIGN PROCESS AND ALL OF
OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
ASSOCIATIONS.
SUCH AS LEAGUE OF CITIES AND
THE.
CALIFORNIA THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ASSOCIATION RURAL
COUNTIES WILL BE DEVELOPING
STRATEGIES TO DO TRAININGS THAT
WORK ACTIVELY WITH THEIR
SCHEDULES FOR TRAININGS AND
INCORPORATE THEIR EXPERTISE AS
WELL.
GREAT AND THEN THE SECOND
QUESTION AND. I THINK YOU GAVE A
GOOD SUMMARY OF FIVE WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING TO RESPOND TO HUDSON
LETTER. ARE THERE ANY ASPECTS OF
WHAT HAD IT'S ASKING FOR THAT
YOU THINK.
ARE EITHER UNREASONABLE OR
THINGS IT WILL JUST BE DIFFICULT
FOR US TO ADDRESS READY FEEL
COMFORTABLE THAT.
THE STATE IS IN A GOOD POSITION
TO RESPOND WELL TO WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ASKING FOR.
I THINK WE CAN GET TO A GOOD
PLACE TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO
THE HAD MONITORING UNDER ONE OF
THOSE THE SIGNIFICANT THINGS
THAT THEY CARE ABOUT IS
CERTAINLY OUR EXPENDITURE RAINY.
REDUCING THE PROGRAM INCOME
THAT IS OUTSTANDING. AND THEN
THE ON SITE MONITORING AND SO
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES FOR WITH
CALIFORNIA'S JUST THE GEOGRAPHY
OF CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE I'M
WORKING. WITH HUD IN TERMS OF A
RISK BASED APPROACH TO HOW WE
MIGHT CONSIDER ARE. IN PERSON AS
WELL AS DESK MONITORING. GREAT
UP I THINK IF YOU THINK TWO
YEARS AGO I CARRIED A BILL.
THAT EIGHT CITIES* TO DO TO
HELP MAKE IT EASIER TO GET CBG
FUNDS OUT AND IF THERE'S ANY
ASSISTANCE YOU NEED PARTICULARLY
AS WE'RE TRYING TO BE RESPONSIVE
TO THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
HAPPEN TO BE HELPFUL.
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
AND I ALSO THINK WITH PARTY FOR
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF
HAS BEEN GRADING WORKING WITH
THEM SO THEY CAN VERY MUCH VERY
MUCH.
YOU'RE WELCOME. SOME.
SORRY WITH DOCTOR CHOI.
NOW. I'M CURIOUS. IN INDIA ON
THE FUNDING ALLOCATION ARE.
NOW WE ARE YOU RELYING UPON WHAT
THE STATE CRITERIA WAR NAM
FEDERAL QUOTE Y. TERRIO WHAT
COMBINATION OF.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE WERE
TASKED TO DO IS TO COMPARE THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS AGAINST
WHAT THE STATE REGULATIONS ARE
SO PART OF THE PROCESS WITH THE
REDESIGN GROUP IS TO LOOK AT
WHETHER OR NOT THE STATE
REGULATIONS ARE CREATING ANY
BARRIERS OR ONEROUS. SITUATIONS
SUCH THAT WE SHOULD.
MAKE IT EASIER FOR
JURISDICTIONS TO BE ABLE TO
REVIEWS ARE FUN SENSE OF THAT
ANALYSIS.
IS IS ONGOING AND WILL HAVE THAT
AS PART OF OUR REPORT BACK TO
YOU ON THE THIRTIETH SO THAT YOU
CAN SEE.
WHAT THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS AND
CALIFORNIA'S REQUIREMENTS AND
THEN WHAT THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THIS PROCESS WOULD BE TO TO
MODIFY THE THE GUIDELINES GOING
FORWARD?
THE FULL IS EXAMPLES DO YOU TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION OF LA DOES
THE POPULATION DEMOGRAPHIC UP
BACKGROUND THOUGH OF THE
POPULATION.
O. WARM MARRIED BASIS OUT OF
THE APPLICATION ITSELF FOR.
WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL OF THOSE
FACTORS IN TERMS OF HOW DO WE
ACCEPT APPLICATIONS AND RANK OUR
APPLICATIONS FIRST AND FOREMOST
LOOKING AT WHAT'S GOING TO BE
MOST EXPEDIENT TO GET THE
MONIES.
AWARDED AN EXPANDED BUT
CERTAINLY THINGS ABOUT NEED AND
CAPACITY ARE FACTORED INTO OUR
ANALYSIS.
OKAY IN THERE ARE.
IT IS MEMBER AUTUMN FROM A
STUDIO PARAVAI.
THE ACTUAL OR.
THE.
PORTABLE ODOR.
HOME
OUR ASSISTANT BEATING.
AMOUNT WAS SO.
JUST A TOKEN AMOUNT THE
IT WAS SO ALMOST SO YOU KNOW USE
LISTA AMOUNT.
BUT MOSTLY IT WAS ALL PROGRAM
DRIVEN.
DO YOU EMPHASIZE SO ON THE
PROGRAM'S MORAL AURA HOSTING.
A SUBSIDY.
WELL THE CITY BG PROGRAM HAS A
NUMBER OF ACTIVITIES THAT.
WEEKEND FUND AND THERE ARE
CERTAIN PERCENTAGES THAT.
HAVE BEEN PRESCRIBED.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT AYE I
THINK THERE'S BEEN HISTORICALLY
MAY BE.
.
I CAN'T RECALL THE PERCENTAGE
FOR HOUSING IN OUR THIRTY FIFTY
PERCENT EIGHTY ONE PERCENT SERVE
CURRENTLY THE CBG PROGRAM HAS A.
A TARGET OF FIFTY ONE PERCENT OF
THE FUNDS GOING TO SUPPORT
HOUSING ACTIVITY.
FIFTY ONE PERCENT TO HOSTING.
WADE HAS GONE UP BY.
OKAY THANK.
IF YOU WANT THE PUBLIC WHICH IS
BIG ON THE SIDE OF.
KILL POST PUBLIC COMMENT AND
WILL THIS ITEM OPEN THANK YOU.
MOVING ON TO OUR NEXT ITEM.
ISSUE NUMBER SIX OTHER
PROPOSALS.
SO MISTER CHAIRMAN I HAD THIS
ITEM INCLUDES FOUR DIFFERENT BC
PEACE AND SO I'D JUST LIKE TO
KNOW WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO READ
THE OVERVIEW STATEMENT FOR EACH
OF THEM AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO
DISCUSSION. OKAY SO THE FIRST
ONE IS.
THE REFER PROPERTY AFFORDABLE
SALES PROGRAM.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT REQUEST AN
INCREASE IN REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY. OF THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. AND
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING FROM CALTRANS
FOR EACH CITIES STAFFING
EXPENSES. TO ENSURE THAT CERTAIN
SURPLUS PROPERTY SOLD BY
CALTRANS.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ARE
PRESERVED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
THE NEXT ITEM. IS THE
TRANSACTIONS UNIT FUND SHIFT.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT PHONE NINE
S. B. SEVEN ZERO SEVEN
AUTHORIZED EACH CITY TO EXTEND
AND RESTRUCTURE. THE LOAN TERMS
FOR ITS LEGACY LOAN PROGRAMS
HOWEVER THE ONLY REVENUE
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT THIS
ACTIVITY WERE BOND PROCEEDS THAT
WERE SET ASIDE FOR PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION FROM THE LEGACY
LOAN PORTFOLIO. IN FUND SEVEN
FOURTEEN AND FUND SEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THIRTEEN
EACH CITY CREATED THE
TRANSACTIONS UNIT TO HANDLE THE
NEWLY CREATED.
LOAN PORTFOLIO RESTRUCTURING
PROGRAM.
WHICH AUTHORIZED EACH CITY TO
RESTRUCTURE AND OR EXTEND THE
TERM OF LOANS FROM NEWER
PROGRAMS.
MOST IMPORTANTLY THE LP OUR
PROGRAM ENABLE THE CITY EACH
CHARGE TRANSACTION FEES FOR
RESTRUCTURING ACTIVITIES AND
DEPOSIT THOSE FEES INTO FUND
NINE TWO NINE ELIMINATING THE
NEED TO USE BOND PROCEEDS FROM
FUND SEVEN FOURTEEN AND SPUN
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
TO CONTINUE RESTRUCTURING AND
EXTENDING OLDER RENTAL HOUSING
PROGRAM LOANS EACH CITY REQUESTS
THE FOLLOWING.
A TECHNICAL BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS
SHIFTING EXPENDITURES BETWEEN
THE FOLLOWING FUNDS.
ONE MILLION EIGHT HUNDRED AND
NINETY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE REVERTING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FUND SEVEN FOURTEEN.
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE SAFETY AND
HOUSING REHABILITATION BOND
ACCOUNT SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT. AND
AN ACCOUNT WITHIN THE HOUSING
REHABILITATION LOAN FUND NINE
TWO NINE.
AND ONE MILLION EIGHT HUNDRED
NINETY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
THE HOUSING REHABILITATION LOAN
FUND NINE TWO NINE.
THE NEXT ITEM IS THE MOBILE HOME
PURCHASE PROGRAM. TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
ADMINISTERS THE MOBILE HOME PARK
REHABILITATION AND RESIDENTS
OWNERSHIP PROGRAM AND PROP.
TO ENABLE MOBILE HOME PARK
RESIDENTS NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PURCHASE MOBILE
HOME PARKS
IN ORDER TO PRESERVE THE PARK IS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS.
THE CURRENT STATUTE PERMITS
COMPENSATION FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ON BEHALF OF THE
BORROWER ONLY IF THE LOAN IS
FUNDED.
S. B. ONE THIRTY SIX AUTHORIZES
EACH CD TO CONTRACT DIRECTLY
WITH NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS TO
DELIVER TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
QUALIFIED APPLICANTS.
EACH CITY IS REQUESTING ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. AND ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONGOING FROM THE MOBILE
HOME PARK REHABILITATION AND
PURCHASE FUND.
FOR ONE POSITION.
TO OVERSEE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
GRANTS WITH POTENTIAL APPLICANTS
OF THE MOBILE HOME PARK
REHABILITATION RESIDENTS
OWNERSHIP PROGRAM. PURSUANT TO
CHAPTER SEVEN SIXTY SIX STATUTES
OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN S. B.
ONE THIRTY SIX.
AND THEN THE LAST ITEM IS THE
MOBILE HOME RELEASE OF
LIABILITY.
PRIOR TO S. B. FIVE FORTY TO.
EXISTING LOT DID NOT SPECIFY. IF
THE BUYER OR SELLER IS OBLIGATED
TO COMPLETE AND SUBMIT A
REGISTRATION APPLICATION FOR THE
TITLE TO BE TRANSFERRED TO THE
NEW OWNER.
ONCE THE SALE HAS BEEN COMPLETED
IN THE TITLE SIGNED OVER TO THE
BUYER THE SELLER BELIEVED THAT
ALL TAX LIABILITY WAS NOW THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE BUYER.
HOWEVER. THE BUYER OFTEN NOT
AWARE OF THAT WAS OFTEN NOT
AWARE OF THE NEED TO REGISTER
THE MOBILE HOME WITH EACH CD.
AND LEFT THE SELLERS STILL
LIABLE FOR ALL TAXES AND FEES
OAT.
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS STATUTE
WILL ENABLE EACH CD TO
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
REGISTRATION OF MOBILE HOMES AND
PROVIDE SECURITY AND STABILITY
FOR THE CURRENT RUN OWNERS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT REQUEST
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. AND TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING FROM THE MOBILE
HOME A MANUFACTURED HOME
REVOLVING FUND.
FOUR THREE POSITIONS TO
IMPLEMENT THE NOTICE OF TRANSFER
AND RELEASE OF LIABILITY
PROVISIONS OF CHAPTER EIGHT
THIRTY TWO STATUTES OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN S. B. FIVE
FORTY TWO.
COULD YOU LL.
FINANCE.
INCOMES THE COMMITTEE.
EMMA THE POLITICIANS SPEAK
TWELVE O'CLOCK PUBLIC COMMENT
SUBTLE BE HELD OPEN.
MOVING ON OUR SIDE OF ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN.
DEVIATES SYSTEMATIC LITIGATION
YOU
.
WE'VE MY NAME'S NELSON CHAN I'M.
IF COUNSEL WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF.
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TO
LISA SWAN AGAIN AND I AM THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
ADMINISTRATION PAMPLIN IN
HOUSING.
AND I'LL GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED.
SO OUR DISKS
SYSTEMIC DISCRIMINATION REQUEST
DID THE H. RECEIVES
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND COMPLAINTS OF
DISCRIMINATION ALLEGING
COMPLAINTS OF DISCRIMINATION PER
YEAR. ON IN OTHER VIOLATIONS OF
THE LAWS THAT WE ENFORCE.
THROUGH WORK SHARE AGREEMENTS
THAT WE HAVE WITH THE FEDERAL E.
E. OC AND HEARD. THEY GIVE US
MONEY FOR CASES WE INVESTIGATE
THAT ALSO ALLEGED VIOLATIONS OF
FEDERAL LAW.
HOWEVER THERE'S A DIFFERENCE IN
THE AMOUNT OF FEDERAL FUNDING WE
RECEIVE AND.
OUR AUTHORITY AND SO WE LEAVE A
POSITION VACANT IN ORDER TO
COVER THAT AMOUNT
SO OUR REQUEST IS TO TAKE A
POSITION CURRENTLY FUNDED FROM
THE FEDERAL TRUST FUND. AND MOVE
IT TO OUR LITIGATION FUN.
THIS FUN WHAT'S CREATED TO
DEPOSIT ATTORNEY FEES THAT WE
RECEIVED WHEN CASES ARE SETTLED
OR WHEN WERE SUCCESSFUL AT
TRIAL.
IN THE FUNDS CAN BE USED TO
SUPPORT LITIGATION EFFORTS
SO WE LIKE TO TAKE A POSITION
AGAIN FROM THE FEDERAL TRUST
FUND MOVED TO LITIGATION FINE
AND SUPPORT THE POSITION.
FROM THE LITIGATION PINE THAT
WOULD GIVE US AN ATTORNEY IN
EXTRA TURNING. TO PURSUE
SYSTEMIC DISCRIMINATION CASE
BOTH AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE
MONEY THAT WE RECEIVE FROM ALL
CASES THAT WE SETTLE ON WILL
SUPPORT THIS POSITION ON AN
ONGOING BASIS.
THANK YOU ALSO ALSO NETIQUETTE
MACHINERY TO THIS TIME OKAY SURE
SO ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT AB ONE
ZERO ZERO EIGHT.
WE CALL THAT ARE JOB APPLICANT
CRIMINAL HISTORY.
SO AB ONE ZERO ZERO EIGHT
CHAPTER SEVEN EIGHTY NINE
STATUTES OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IT IMMENSE THE FEE
HARD TO MAKE IT UNLAWFUL FOR ALL
EMPLOYERS PUBLIC AND PRIVATE. TO
SEEK CONVICTION HISTORY
INFORMATION UNTIL A CONDITIONAL
OFFER OF EMPLOYMENT IS MADE OR
TO INCLUDE ANY QUESTIONS.
SEEKING DISCLOSURE OF AN
APPLICANT'S CONVICTION HISTORY
ON A JOB APPLICATION. IT ALSO
SETS FORTH RULES AND PROCEDURES
REGARDING HOW EMPLOYERS MAY
CONSIDER CONVICTION HISTORY. HOW
PLAYERS MUST NOTIFY APPLICANTS
WERE BEING REJECTED BECAUSE OF
CONVICTION HISTORY? AND HOW JOB
APPLICANTS MAY CONDUCT AN APPEAL
OF THE EMPLOYMENT DENIAL.
SOLD THE EX THE STATUTE EXEMPTS
CERTAIN POSITIONS FROM ITS
REQUIREMENTS IT ALSO CREATES A
NEW CLASS PRESS OF EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION THAT WE MUST
ARMED LITIGATE. UNDER THIS
REQUEST WE ARE SEEKING IN ONE
POINT NINE MILLION IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN. AND
ONE POINT TWO MILLION ONGOING IN
NINE POSITIONS TO HANDLE THE
WORKLOAD THAT WE ESTIMATE WILL
BE GENERATED FROM THIS NEW LAW.
AND THEN IN TERMS OF SB SIXTY
THREE CHAPTER SIX
EIGHTY SIX STATUES OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. IT
ESTABLISHES THE NEW PARENT LEAVE
ACT WITHIN THE WITHIN THE FEE
HA.
IT EXPANDS THE BABY BONDING
COMPONENT OF SIFRA BY MAKING IT
UNLAWFUL FOR AN EMPLOYER WITH
TWENTY OR MORE EMPLOYEES.
TO REFUSE TO ALLOW AN ELIGIBLE
EMPLOYEE TO TAKE UP TO TWELVE
WEEKS OF JOB PROTECTED PARENTAL
LEAVE. TO BOND WITH A NEW CHILD
WITHIN ONE YEAR OF THE CHILD'S
BIRTH ADOPTION OR FOSTER CARE.
AND THAT'S IF THEY MEET THE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS.
S. B. SIXTY THREE ALSO PROHIBITS
AN EMPLOYER FROM REFUSING TO
MAINTAIN AND PAY FOR COVERAGE
UNDER A GROUP HEALTH PLAN.
DURING THE DURATION OF THE LEAVE
OR RETALIATING AGAINST AN
EMPLOYEE FOR EXERCISING THEIR
RIGHTS UNDER THIS REQUEST WE ARE
REQUESTING ON TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN.
IT'S SEVEN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
TWO HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
ONGOING FOR.
TO HEPA HE'S.
THANK YOU.
.
ILLEGAL ON BOTH ITEMS.
FINANCE.
THE FORCES IN THE COMMITTEE.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
DEREK MISSIONS ALL THIS AUTUMN
HOLD BOTH ITEMS OPEN SOLDIER
THAT THANK YOU FOR IF YOU.
WE'VE GOT TO OUR.
SADDAM.
OTHER NUMBER ELEVEN.
CALIFORNIASCIENCE CENTER
INCREASE.
CAME MUSEUM.
I AM BRIAN CASH FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY HERE
REPRESENTING THAT CALIFORNIA
AFRICAN AMERICAN MUSEUM.
THIS PROPOSAL IS TO INCREASE A.
TEMPORARY HELP BY SEVEN HUNDRED
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
FOR THAT CALIFORNIA. ATARI BY
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF FOR THAT CALIFORNIA
AFRICAN AMERICAN MUSEUM THIS.
TEMPORARY HELP WILL HELP WITH
THE.
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN VISITORS
THAT THEY'VE HAD OVER THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS.
TO THEIR EXHIBITS AND ALSO
THEIR NEW PROGRAMS THAT THEY'VE
BEEN IMPLEMENTING.
THEY'RE KIND OF A VICTIM OF
THEIR OWN SUCCESS AND THIS WILL
HELP ASSURE THE SAFETY AND AND
ALSO THE SUCCESS OF THE
EXHIBITS.
LL.
FINANCE.
BECAUSE THE COMMITTEE.
A PUBLIC COMMENT ASIDE.
IT'S AT EXPO PARK.
BUSINESS AND PARK RIGHT NEXT TO
IT YEAH USC.
OKAY THE CONDITION TOLL A LOT OF
OPEN FULL HOLD OPEN THANK YOU
WRESTLER BY NUMBER TWELVE
INCREASE IN CALIFORNIA SCIENCE
CENTER. REIMBURSEMENT FORTY.
JEFF RUDOLPH DIRECTIVE THE
CALIFORNIA SCIENCE CENTER THIS
ITEM IS TO. INCREASE
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY IN
ASSOCIATION WITH THE SCIENCE
CENTER SCHOOL WHICH WOULD
JOINTLY OPERATE WITH PHIL
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT ON.
WOMEN AGREEMENT WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT BAY.
PAY OF MAINTENANCE COSTS AND WE
JUST NEGOTIATED INCREASE LAST
YEAR BASED ON INFLATION THIS.
ALSO SUSPEND THEM MONEY.
LL.
FINANCE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
OKAY WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN.
OUR LAST ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
INCREASE IN OFFICE OF EXPOSITION
PARK MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY.
I BRING CASH AGAIN FROM THE
NATURAL RESOURCES IN CITY.
FOR EXPOSITION PARK TO THE THE
INCREASE REIMBURSEMENT THIRTY
IS.
.
FOR THE.
ENFORCEMENT PROCEEDS BE. AT THE.
.
LOS ANGELES RAMS GAMES.
PHILIP.
FINANCE.
SEE WE HAVE ONE SPEAKER FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT.
SENATOR.
YEAH I'D APOLOGIZE MY ITEM IS
NOT NECESSARILY ON THE AGENDA
BUT SAY A TRAILER BILL AND I'M
ROD RIGHT REPRESENTING.
THE FOUNDATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCIENCE CENTER.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS WE WERE
LOOKING TO DO MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
IS OF ENGAGE.
AND WHAT WOULD BE OUR THIRD
PHASE OF A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP IN THIS CASE WOULD
BE A LEASE PURCHASE AGREEMENT
TO.
BILL.
THE HANGAR IN EFFECT FOR THE
SPACE SHUTTLE A SOME OF YOU
MIGHT REMEMBER IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN.
THE SCIENCE CENTER WAS
SUCCESSFUL IN WINNING A NATIONAL
COMPETITION TO ACQUIRE THE
ENDEAVOR SPACE SHUTTLE.
IT IS BEEN DOCKED AT THE SCIENCE
CENTER NOW
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE. WE
ACTUALLY ATTRACT SOMEWHERE NEAR
A MILLION PEOPLE A YEAR. ALL WHO
COME TO SEE IT THE IDEA HERE
WOULD BE THAT THE FOUNDATION.
AND THE STATE WOULD ENGAGE AND
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP.
WHEREUPON WE WOULD BUILD A
BUILDING.
THAT WOULD BE A PERMANENT
FACILITY TO HOUSE THE SHUTTLE.
I THINK SOME OF YOU HAVE SEEN
THE DRAWINGS THAT WE HAVE
SOMEHOW OUT BYPASS THAT. ON
THERE'S NO MONEY THAT WOULD NEED
TO CHANGE HANDS IN THIS BUDGET
YEAR IN FACT WE'RE LOOKING TO DO
IS TO EXTEND THE SAME TERMS.
THAT TOOK PLACE IN THE FACE TO
PROPOSAL SOME TWENTY YEARS AGO.
AND THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO
COMPLETE FACED THREE THE
FOUNDATION IS GOING TO PUT UP.
SOMEWHERE NORTH OF TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SOME ODD OF WHICH WE
HAVE ALREADY RAISED.
OF THE STATE WOULD PUT UP
SOMEWHERE AROUND FORTY OF FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. AND THAT WOULD
BE PAID IN INCREMENTS BY
EXTENDING THE LEAST.
TERM AGREEMENT THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE FACE TO AND
JUST ROLLING THAT OVER TO. OF
FACE THREE. OF THEM WE WERE
DISCUSSING IT LAST YEAR WE HAD
SOME ISSUES THAT CAME UP SO WE
WANTED TO PUT THIS UP AGAIN THIS
YEAR BECAUSE. A AGAIN WE WOULD
LIKE TO GET ON WITH THE PROCESS
OF BUILDING.
ON THAT FACED THREE THAT WAS A
PART OF THE MASTER PLAN. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SCIENCE CENTER THAT
GOES BACK TO NINETEEN NINETY
THREE.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
WE SHOULD.
OKAY BLESSING OF OUR HEARING.
ADJOURNMENTS MEETING THANK YOU